Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello, hello, hello!
I apologize that this is a very, uh, um, a very early stream
for Resident Evil, for Resident Evil 4.
Uh, I just want, I wanted to start early today because I was
like, okay, um, if we're doing a long stream, I don't want
to get to the scary part when it's nighttime.
I want to get to the scary part.
When the sun is just going down.
So, so that is why.
I know it's a different time slot.
Compared to, like, the part one of Resident Evil 4.
But, like, guys, it is for the sake of my sanity.
That we play the game.
When it's not that dark.
It's not cheating.
It's the sun.
sky so so that is why we are playing it at an earlier time
slot because like i said i don't want to you know i don't i
don't want to get to this like if we're doing long stream
most likely some of the scarier parts happen at a later time
so like you know maybe if i play for like five or six hours
um and it's scary i can look outside and be like oh the sun
is still out So, like, this is not real.
When it gets dark, I can be like, I'll be like, there's a
possibility this can happen.
But when I see that the sun is still out, I'd be like, it's
not real because the sun is still out.
H, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Perfect time for E.
Almost set to 9 p.m.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whenever I do play Visage, I'm gonna make sure It's the
1230pm slot Because there's no fucking way I'm playing
Visage when the sun is out There's no fucking way You can't
make me Alright Alright here we go I already forgot all the
controls by the way So this is, you guys gotta help me I
already, I actually forgot all the Fucking controls for this
game After like A day I just forgot how to play videos games
in general oh this part okay we can i mean we can we watch
this now when day breaks you too will join our covenant to
share left click does stuff oh really oh my god oh yeah he
like he got like injected with things He became Coca-Cola
Bear.
Oh, yeah, it's Adam Sadler.
Trey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Past Doki made the right choice.
Have lots of fun, Doki.
Can't catch the stream right now, but I'll definitely watch
the VOD or chapter 5 that I make it on time later.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Aphelion, thank you for the 20 gifted chips.
All right, here we go.
to melee.
I'll figure this out.
Condor 1 to roost.
Do you read me?
Condor 1?
You've been radio silent for three hours.
Are you alright?
Ma'am, I got injected by Coca-Cola bear.
Or by Adam Sadler.
I don't know which is worse.
Oh, F.
I figured it out.
F is melee.
I figured it out, guys.
Okay, the only other way I hate playing when the sun is out
is that it makes me realize just how dirty my monitor is
Because when the sign shines just right on your monitor
It's too real That's the only thing I hate about When the
sun is out When it's sunshines Just right You can see
everything on your I'm gonna fucking give me a sec guys I
need to close my blinds I can't I can't feel like I don't
want to see I don't want to see I'll fuck up my monitor in
Alright It's okay, the sun is still shining through my
blinds.
Because then...
There we go.
I feel less guilty now.
Ah, shit, I forgot there was...
This was the reason why I stopped playing.
I forgot that this was the reason...
Where the fuck is my map?
Okay.
Where do I go?
Okay, I'm gonna go to the dead end?
Is this dead end?
This is dead end.
Okay.
There must be, like, loot, right?
Oh, wait.
What?
Oh, no.
I'm turning.
I'm hearing the voices.
Oh, no.
I didn't take my meds.
Oh, oh.
I don't like this.
Come out the bush!
Oh, loot.
Oh, this is why I play in the morning!
Okay.
Oh, I'm lost.
Oh, I'm freaking out that I don't even know where to go.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Stop!
I'll never take my...
Oh, hey, Barrow.
Okay, I need to take the Barrow first.
Barrow time.
Oh.
Hello?
Oh, the voices are only in that area.
If I close my eyes.
Okay, money.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, hello?
Hello?
Who's there?
Whoa, whoa, who's there?
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
Oh, the voices are back.
The voices are back.
Get out of the bush!
Oh, no.
What are they even saying?
Oh, there's the bones.
There's the bones.
Oh, there they are.
Oh.
What's going on?
What?
Oh!
Oh, that's a sniper!
Oh, shit!
Where do I...
Dude!
The head?
Where do I shoot?
He has no head!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, you have a head though.
Oh, god.
There you go.
I think that's your head.
Oh, what?
Okay, if I shoot the leg.
If I shoot the leg!
You can't walk, right?
okay okay nope all right shotgun time if it all fails it's
shotgun time oh no oh what flashbang i don't work oh there
it is that flash no no no no no no okay register shortcut
all right there i'll put that here all right i don't have a
lot i don't I don't have a lot of fucking shotgun ammo.
That's great.
I should have not shot the knees when that thing came out.
Alright.
Well, I assume that headshots don't work right now.
I assume that headshots do not work on these guys.
Craft.
Oh, I don't have enough shotgun.
Wait, do I not have enough?
I should have enough.
Yeah.
Okay, we're gonna make shotgun shells.
We're gonna need it.
Alright.
They do?
Oh, they do work?
Oh, okay.
So I just keep aiming the head.
Alright.
Okay.
They still have brains in there.
That's good.
I couldn't tell.
There were like so many things coming out of the head.
I don't know.
Maybe there were like mini brains in like various areas.
Like what's...
I don't know the logic of parasites.
Like I don't know the logic of Resident Evil 4 parasites.
How would I know?
Because I already killed the brain.
Where are the other brains?
Like where?
Oh.
Brains.
Aim for the head tentacles.
I don't know that.
Are there mini brains in the tentacles?
I don't know.
Am I supposed to assume that?
They are weak to...
Yeah.
Yeah, but will they die from light?
They might be weak to light, but will they won't die from
it?
That's the thing.
I need Tetris this.
This is like so fucking messy.
Wait, is that a chocolate bar?
What is this?
Oh, it's a rifle.
I was like, why do I have a chocolate bar?
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Where do I go?
I'm already lost.
Oh, I go...
Oh, wait, what?
There was a way over here?
Oh.
I can barely see it's like the thing I hate is that Leon
doesn't turn on his fucking flashlight like when it's
clearly very whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa who's there I have a
shotgun who's there Leon please just turn on your fucking
flashlight it's so dark like it's I'm turning on this
brightness i can't i i'm fucking i'm fucking blind right now
i can't fucking deal with this leon leon please all i ask
you is to turn on your fucking flashlight jesus christ leon
okay i guess a little better oh my god this is so much oh
thank you thank you
Oh yeah, what is this place?
Leon eats his carrots.
Fuck carrots.
What's carrots done for me?
The shrine of hands.
Girmly grasp it.
Is this the hand guy?
What the fuck do I put in there?
Alright, it's time to figure it out.
Oh god, okay.
There's a boat.
I don't like this.
God, I hate this level so fucking much.
Do I put the head?
Oh, there's the monster I killed.
Oh.
What's in here?
Wait, there's treasures?
Oh, there's a lot of treasures.
Okay, we're gonna have to go there.
And then we have to go there to grab stuff.
Oh my god.
Why is there a maze-like thing here?
I don't like that.
Alright, and then...
So we go there.
And then...
Oh, wait, but there's, like, loot in the middle of the lake.
How do I get to the middle?
I can't fucking swim, apparently.
Wait, is that the right game?
Oh, no, all the games are blurring together.
No, I can't swim.
No, Leon can swim.
Never mind.
Sorry.
All the games are blurring together, because usually I can't
swim.
We have to manually drive the boat myself?
That's fucked up.
Why do I have to drive the boat myself?
That's what the game is for.
That's what cutscenes are for.
Are you telling me I don't get the privilege of cutscenes?
Okay, someone fetched me a rare golden chicken egg.
Oh, shit.
Okay, well, time to see if the chickens will lay me an egg.
Uh, what's in here?
What are you?
The old way shrine.
What door does this open?
All the locations are in.
I can't remember, man.
Wait, I do have to drive the boat!
What?
Where's my cutscene privileges?
Oh no, I have to throw the fucking spear too?
God damn!
I'm so sad!
There's no cutscene privileges!
I have to do this all by hand!
Boop!
I guess I'll grab that $100.
Oh, it's $100 now.
I remember when barrels were a thousand.
Inflation happened.
Do you remember?
Okay, isn't that the boat?
Oh, this was the boat.
Oh, okay.
How do we get into this boat?
How the hell do I get on this boat?
Hello?
Oh, here.
I heard there's a gun here.
Thank you, backseaters.
Alright.
Gun?
No, that is Alexandrite.
Dang, I can't believe I have to play the game.
Oh my god.
Where is the gun?
backseat there's a lot of me gun oh this must be gun gun is
that the pistol wait is that a pistol is that a better
pistol okay red a powerful handgun is burned to grip to vent
the user from loading wait is it is that a better pistol can
i like attach this to wait where's the other is this it okay
sg what is the sg oh this one is that is it does it use
pistol ammo strongest okay all right well goodbye we're
gonna oh oh i don't it only goes to that gun okay uh
equipped uh shortcut bam how much ammo do i have oh it is
but there's no There's no laser though Best damage for slow
reload.
Okay, I'm gonna put this in the storage then goodbye What
was that quote?
I'm done playing with you
Goodbye All right, let's see
Where do we go?
The Lakeside Settlement.
Wait, why the fuck is...
Door with Insignia.
Oh, there's so many things there.
Have I been here before?
What's over there?
There's a door with Insignia.
Oh, wait.
Is that the...
Oh, my God.
There's a hidden area here, too.
Okay, wait.
This is important.
I'm done with.
There's so much loot.
There is so much loot.
Thank God this is...
Thank God the sun is out.
Okay, it's this way.
Right?
Yeah, it's this way.
It's over here.
I have to always tab to look at the map because I'm stupid.
Alright, here we go.
Yay!
Oh, the chickens!
There's so many chickens!
Chicken, chicken.
Time to lay some egg.
Time to lay some golden eggs.
What was this?
do i even have enough okay i do all right guys guys this is
it this is your job to lay me some eggs come on i can wait
all day i can just do super chat reading come on chickens i
can just do super chat reading oh there we go all right i
don't need you anymore Oh my god, that's way too many eggs.
Give me a sec.
I'm done with all of you too.
No, it's a waste of bullets.
Sorry, that's actually a waste of bullets.
You're not worth my time.
Let's see.
How the fuck do I get over to this?
Oh, I have to go through here.
Okay, where the fuck is the merchant?
Merchant!
Oh, I have to...
Okay, I'm gonna... I need to, like...
Okay, you know what?
No, I'm gonna go over here and grab some more treasures.
Treasure time.
That's...
What?
You don't eat chicken?
You can't say that.
Okay.
Oh, wait, wait.
I don't even have to...
Why do I even need to use my fucking thing?
I can just ram into it.
You can't say that unless you're vegan or vegetarian.
Okay.
If you're neither of these you can't say that Because you
you've eaten KFC before
Don't think I don't know There you Not that Where do you
think fucking fried chicken comes from Chicken
Where do you think fried chicken came from?
Hey, is that Neanna Jones?
Okay.
Bro, it takes like 20 years to die.
Alright, here you go.
Oh, wait.
I heard the reload.
It's like, oh my god.
Oh my god, the reload!
Okay, now I understand what you mean by the reload being,
like, super low.
Shink, shink, shink, shink, shink!
Shink, shink, shink, shink!
Oh, I fucked up the shink!
Guys, I fucked up the shink because I saw the thing, and
then I was like, I should press like, I didn't realize it
would take that, I didn't realize it would take that long to
shink somebody.
That was, that was an oopsie there.
admit i might have messed up a little there there was a
quick time prompt and i chose to ignore it because i thought
i would shink faster i thought i was faster than the quick
time prompt uh light there you go i legitimately thought i
was faster
oh man there's definitely people here oh man i could feel
that i'm gonna go in there later what will it could we go
back to the lake when it's daytime is that possible do we
come back here do we come back here when it's daytime
what's the point right they give it a five give the shoes
thank you thank you we don't that's up that actually is up
man that's that's fucked up man i wish we came back here
when it was daytime all right use there is no sun sad i'm so
sad but you're not space anymore mike thank you for that one
gift that ship thank you thank you okay all right let us
we'll go we'll do the oh my god i don't want to do the house
man why why is this so dark no there's people here there's
no way a house like this is empty when there's so much look
there's no way i refuse to believe this house is unoccupied
oh my god i don't have any keys wait is it even worth it i
don't oh my god does this need a key this do i have the key
for this
look at the dinner it's just fish it's a fishing village oh
my god Oh!
No key for that one.
Alright.
This does not look like an empty house.
This looks like a house.
Wait, have I already...
Yeah, I've already fucking done that.
This looks like a house that's about to fucking gank me.
Hello.
Hello guys.
hello hello what's this is this the photo oh this i put that
there oh i hate this i hate this so much i don't feel safe
you say i'm safe but i definitely do not feel safe oh my god
there's a ladder bro what's how worth of it how how worth it
is it for me to go there
how worth it how worth how worth it it's so worth all right
how much do you want to bet guys how much do you want to bet
this of how worth is this are you willing to bet bet for it
all right i'm going in i'm going in i'm running in i don't
care i'm running in i'm running in in i'm running in i'm not
looking i'm running in if i don't look wait what oh it was
worth it that's money three years ago my beloved daughter
passed away shortly after giving birth to a son since then
the boy has grown considerably he's a very curious child and
has a true thirst for knowledge he even tries to um follow
after me when i go out hunting I can't take my eyes off him
for a second.
Whenever we walk in the forest, he always asks me to tell
stories.
He's very fond of Don.
Although he's small, the boy is smart and observant beyond
his years.
If he weren't stuck here, he might become a scholar.
I was a careless fool.
I could have sworn I shot clean through the wolf's head, and
yet it lunged at me.
I was able to make it back to the cabin.
But my wound is swollen and discolored.
Seeing the boy's worried eyes.
My body moves on its own.
Oh no, he got infected by the bad woes.
Oh no!
My boy moves on its own.
My body, am I going mad?
I can't die now and leave the boy behind.
Dear God, please protect him.
Oh.
God, now it's to go back.
Bro, now it's the walk back.
whose shoes are those oh man have to walk back oh I hate
this bro I fucking hate this house man put me back in the
forest at least there's like sky you know at least the sky
is out ha my paranoia it's rising okay here we go miss
opportunity for optional bikinis for leon modders do you
hear that to be fair i don't think i've seen like a mod for
like a naked leon like you know shirtless leon let me phrase
that better a shirtless leon i do not think i've it all
right let's see i saw a lot of mods for ashley though what
should i was like we're why do you not give us what we
really want shirtless leon where is my shirtless leon okay
oh hey i didn't open this before there is oh my god link for
for um scientific reasons for a reason search purposes.
Wait, what is over here?
I've never been here before.
What would be here?
Guys, for research purposes, I need to know what to look
for.
Guys, it is clearly for research.
Because someone cast a gigantic fish that lives in the lake
for me wait oh i just have to shoot it sell it wait don't i
have one yeah isn't that the oh it's the lunker bass okay
not the not the other one wait what's over here
what the is over here ashley oh that is not ashley oh that
is not oh oh oh oh Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
The hell is going on here.
What?
What is this?
Who are you?
You're not my top topic, Ashley.
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
Wait, the mod is called shirtless Leon.
Like, they actually have shirtless Leon.
Oh.
Guys, what if I...
I won't, guys.
Don't worry.
I won't do that.
I still want to be monetized, everybody.
I still want to be monetized.
What's up here, though?
What's up here?
I didn't even realize that you actually do have it.
Those mad men.
Horse altar?
They are all women.
Is that what Ashley's for?
Oh, I don't like it.
I feel like I'm going to get fucking...
I got key.
Oh, that must have been for the chest.
Oh, my God.
Dude, I'm getting so paranoid from all of this.
I feel so much paranoia right now.
I don't feel safe.
Wait.
Where is that?
Wait, where is that?
I hear it, but where is it?
You hear that, right?
Where is it?
Where?
You hear that, right?
You hear the toy?
I swear, I'm not fucking going crazy.
Oh, there!
There he is!
Okay, there he is.
Oh, my God.
I just...
Ah!
Why?
I'm so paranoid.
There's so much paranoia here.
I shouldn't feel this safe.
I don't feel safe at all.
D-Dragon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Shout out to the tramp staff, Leon mod, and to the redacted
mod too.
Why do you know so much about that, D-Dragon?
Why do you know that?
Huh?
You know, when I was researching mods, those were definitely
not downloaded a lot.
Oh, no.
It's the evil wolf.
Oh, it's super evil wolf.
Is evil wolf dead?
Oh, no.
Super wolf.
super wolves I'm not ready for super wolves it's that super
wolves oh what the fuck what are you guys
they're working together
oh shit oh fuck okay that's on me okay okay how the fuck do
I miss that though like oh Okay, I'm just gonna use my
shotgun.
Fuck this.
This is, like, way too much worth.
Alright.
Come over here.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, I did not like Super Wolf.
I did not like Super Wolf at all.
Super Wolf did not make me comfortable.
All right, let's craft some more shotgun shells here.
All right, nice.
We'll just eat an egg.
We have so many eggs.
Give that.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your face is so smug.
Can't decide if I want to protect you or bully you.
Good job, boat babysitting.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jesus Christ, not super wolf.
Where is here?
Is this important?
I can't.
guess we're treasure?
Oh, there's a typewriter there.
Like, how important is here?
How important is here?
Not yet?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I guess we leave.
I guess we're fine.
We already killed super wolves.
Oh, we've got to unlock this chest, though.
Turn on your light.
There we go.
Thank you, Leon.
all right you should have the key now for this what is it ah
gold bar nice there's so much money i like money just like
mr crabs myoshi all right here we go you'll be around back
to the village eventually you guys just told me i would
never be back here that's why i fucking went here That's the
only reason why I went there because you guys said it
wouldn't be important
Can't believe it would this be important Guys is this
entrance important enough guys I need a no it's complicated
Is this entrance important
okay now i'm gonna i feel do it for the money okay but how
much money though like how much
like is it worth the ammo like here right here is it worth
the ammo for this oh i mean i could like fucking poop all
right oh hey there's a lot of money hey there is money
I think I'm gonna die in this cave Bro, I feel like I'm just
gonna fucking die in this cave Oh hey, look, there is money
Look at that, all the money Oh, but I caught up in here But
there is a typewriter here Maybe I should just go for the
typewriter here Oh my god, I hate Oh my god, I do not feel
safe in here I feel like this cave is just gonna collapse.
This is like a bait cave.
This does not feel like the safe cave.
It feels like the bait cave.
Okay.
Oh, there's a place for me to dock my boat.
Is this the one with the gators?
What do you mean by that?
Excuse me?
What do you mean?
the one with the gators there's crocodiles now or alligator
i don't who cares you're basically the same thing like oh my
god man don't worry about it
gators in europe oh my god true what the how are you here
who brought you here are you an invasive species all right
nice okay did i grab all the treasure i did all right and
then i fucking just ride back to over here oh i saw that
treasure over here too oh no they've escaped from the zoo oh
no bro i haven't made any progress on the story i've just
been looting man i i just i i made zero progress from this
this is why I started this early today.
Thank you.
I've just been looting.
over Ashley.
I still have yet to fucking find Ashley.
This whole game is about protecting Ashley.
And I'm definitely not doing my job.
Alright, here we go.
Like, the president purposely hired me to save Ashley.
But I'm just here looting.
Alright, nice.
I am nice.
Wait, there is a chest here, right?
That can open.
Can I open this now?
No, I don't have the key.
God damn it.
All right, sir, I got the golden egg.
So I don't think you have the super chat.
Thank you.
Get here.
I hardly know her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
I got you that.
What the fuck?
Okay, that's a lot of shit.
That's a lot of shit.
Okay, let me give you the golden egg.
chicken egg first nice you're right she's probably fine
she's probably okay guys i don't know why your guys are so
worried probably okay okay what's the matchup 1.2 for uh
different colors okay i have different colors boop boop all
right nice now you're now you're more pretty All right,
cool, elegant headdress.
Uh, wait, can I not?
Can I put you ahead?
Yeah, let me put stones in you.
Excuse you?
Excuse me?
Let me...
Are that not stone?
Oh, they're not.
I thought every time I see a circle, I think stone.
I was like, I can put stones in you.
All right, there's not...
It looked like it had it.
Okay, I can sell this key now.
And then I'll sell...
Oh, my God, 12,000.
I'm fucking rich.
Okay, and then I'll sell this.
And I'll sell...
Oh, my God, 19,000?
Guys, don't talk to me.
I'm...
Don't talk to me unless you have a splendid banger.
Okay.
All right, we can sell all of this.
Nice.
Hoop.
Oh, my God!
93 000 this is good okay we can get rid of wait can i get
rid of my normal pistol now that money changed you
do i sell the north i can yeah i can sell the sg goodbye
you're never coming back to me all right here you go yeah
this one okay yeah all right i'll sell it nice all right now
i can just upgrade my new baby okay how much does my
durability right now you know i have so much money i don't
even care all right where is where is my new baby here go
power yes okay i heard the reload i need up the reload speed
right uh loony close to the sun okay i can i'm gonna get the
reload speed because the reload speed for this is dog now
all right nice all right and then what else uh you know what
what else i have 81 000 i can do whatever the fuck no i'm
gonna do the power for the knife too i'm so rich it doesn't
matter i have so much loot oh i should sell the i should
sell the laser site which one is the laser site is this one
this one right
one right i for yeah this is for the sg and the punisher
wait well i'll have one for punisher is the punisher better
or is my is my current gun better chat is a punisher or this
this one better don't store it we need power is always a
safe bet for it does sit no no you don't uh punisher sucks
okay wait oh my gosh wait what what are these leon with
shotgun i can sell my I can sell myself, but that's the
charm.
Okay, I'll sell the laser sight.
Okay, I'm gonna sell it then.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm selling it.
You know what?
It's alright.
Nice.
We have a lot of...
We have so much money.
Okay, well, let me see.
Oh, case upgrade!
We need that.
Okay.
Is that everything?
Well, let's attach...
We don't need it.
What?
That's okay.
We don't need fucking grenades.
all we need is our our fucking guns like we're not gonna
take the cheap route with nades also i'm pretty sure i'm
gonna need myself anyway so i'm like i'm i low-key think i
am definitely gonna like accidentally grenade myself so i
don't i don't think i should
slash grenade all right what i okay i'll buy it i have so
much money i can waste money right I can like, okay, I'm
going to upgrade the power.
Will I ever get a better pistol?
Will I ever get a better pistol, guys?
If not, I will.
No?
Is this the best pistol I'm going to get?
Yes?
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to all in.
All in.
All fucking in and I might as well get the reload speed
because the reload speed is fucking slow All right, now I'm
poor guys now you can talk to me again I unless you have
that bangle unless you have the bangle
Okay Why the fuck would I want like a different case color
like what
I'm just like you guys.
I'm one of the people.
I'm one of the people now.
Where the fuck is the typewriter?
Oh, there you go.
Nice.
Oh, there's a buffs?
Wait, what?
Where's the buff?
Oh, increases the drop.
Wait, do I buy it?
Aesthetic.
Wait, what's the white one?
What does the white one do?
What does the white case do?
Oh, I know.
How do I know what the fuck the white case does?
The case or the stock?
Don't buy it?
I was like, buy it.
Don't buy it.
But what does that white case do?
I'm so curious.
What does it do?
Oh, increased drop.
rate for handgun okay no the ammo is better the ammo is much
better what a fuck of course i would pick the ammo yeah the
ammo is better than this cast thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you are you saying we have no trap okay i
saved already all right uh we mean i want to go here there
must be like stuff here too so all right nice my fucking i'm
so kinky now Am I going the right way?
I am.
Okay, that's good.
I always need to know if I'm going the right way.
God, they do this ambience so well.
I'm like super fucking paranoid every time.
Everywhere I go, I'm thinking, am I gonna die here?
Am I...
Right here, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You mean Leon?
Yeah, search up Leon inflation.
oh wait this is where i was i don't have any uh i don't have
this though
all right let's see here we go well i'm not telling you guys
to search it up i'm talking about that one guy
I know what you're into.
Okay, let's see.
I need to go here.
Miro Cave.
And also...
Yeah, this one.
Alright, there you go.
Get the bass?
Where is that?
Okay, where's the...
Alright, we'll get that later.
That's not important, guys.
Let's see if we have to go to this area to get the location.
There has to be people in there.
Oh shit!
Sorry.
I was too busy looking at my chat.
All right, here you go.
Let's see.
Is this it?
Yeah, this is it.
actually thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
which way okay i mean obviously it can't be that easy right
no good yeah i fucking knew it i was like there's no way
it's that easy it never makes things easy for you all right
let's see oh no not the whispers
It's just this guy.
Give me a sec.
I'm reloading.
Okay, give me a sec.
Wait, where are you going?
Okay.
I was like, where are you going?
Alright, here you go.
Nice.
Is there more people coming over?
No?
Okay, I need to go see if there's loot here.
First.
Alright.
Wait.
Oh, there is loot.
Nice.
I fucking knew it.
Every time there's a little hole, there's loot.
Nice money.
I'll never be as rich as I was before.
I felt so strong.
Oh, no.
Please, am I fast enough?
No, I was too fast enough.
I was not fast enough.
Okay.
No, my shotgun.
I was not fast enough, guys.
All right, nice.
I'll be fast enough.
Okay, I'm fast enough this time.
Yes, I'm never fast enough.
Hello?
All right.
May they?
Oh, not nice.
Not nice.
That is a fucking bomb.
I didn't have time to shoot it.
It's okay.
We're fine here.
Oh, nice!
They're burning themselves!
Yay!
more time to reload what what the fuck oh fuck okay all
right we're just gonna get you out of here oh my god please
tell me you guys have more ammo later on my ammo resources
is not good right now wait did he like blew himself up
that's really convenient wait what happened to that one guy
throwing bombs God, God, I hate that ambience.
Alright, we need more...
Oh, we always need more shotgun, man.
We always need more shotgun.
No, we don't have enough!
Okay, we gotta need to find more.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see.
Hello?
Oh, wait.
Is that it?
No.
Oh, my God.
I don't need rifle ammo!
Hello?
Right away.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello?
Okay, what do I need to do?
All right, there's treasure here, and then there's a shrine
here.
Okay.
Where do I go?
Is this a rifle?
No, this is a waste.
Rifle is for bosses only.
These guys are too small.
Okay.
These guys are not worth it.
Are you...
Are they a boss?
No.
I am trying to set a presidency here.
Okay?
They need to know their worth.
And they are not worth rifles.
They are not...
They are...
Dude, they are not worth rifle privileges.
Not everybody deserves to be a rifle.
What the fuck?
What?
Oh, shit, there he is.
I was like, what?
I'm so...
Oh, what the fuck?
Where did you get here?
Oh, God.
I don't like this.
Whoa!
Mr. Gremlin!
Oh, wait.
I can't reload.
No, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't do not.
Okay, finally.
I only have one ammo, one bullet.
One bullet and a dream.
Wait, is he dead?
Oh, my God.
I hear so many things going on around me.
There's way too many sounds.
There's way too many.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
There's way too many sounds going on.
oh okay thank god please be hang gun ammo please be nice
nice okay where am i what the fuck okay we're okay we're
okay we don't stealth in here
okay you can't go anywhere here oh oh nice all right nice
okay there's no such thing as stealth here in this
neighborhood how the do i get to this side why is there why
did they paint it yellow i'm too stupid why did they what
does this mean i can't kick this the boxes were yellow that
meant kick this is yellow what does this mean that's what it
means okay i know what it means now all right this line this
line okay guys I figured it out I know what it means now I
realized it was a puzzle I mean oh my god what the fuck is
this stupid-ass puzzle look I didn't look left okay I didn't
see there was a button right here i mean how many times i
have to press this oh three there's three buttons okay this
this this this this okay clear them does it come in order
guys is there an order to these buttons what could that
button mean okay there's like that all right
I know there's like one more guy.
There he is.
There he is lurking.
I knew you were still alive.
Nice.
That's fine.
I know like it might be a little waste of a bullet.
But no, he's too far from...
No!
It was too far!
There we go.
Nice.
That has to be the last one.
The order is no ice cream.
extra fat every oh give a fuck up
all right let's see i only found two of these oh there's
more loot there's more loot i love loot i love loot nice
loot's my favorite metty what could the puzzle symbols mean
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you wow nice
you know what bye you might if you live through this i'll
let you be rifled wait oh what is she i didn't see him
behind okay now okay i i was like i heard something behind
me but i was like no there's no way
a minute okay but look at those reflexes though those were
some sick ass reflexes
you have to admit those reflexes were pretty sick all right
oh circle circle circle and then circle and then that and
then that was like two sides together okay circle it was
like oh my god why can't circle this okay it was not that
what the fuck is it over there what is this what the What
the fuck is this?
What is this?
This is also circle.
This is... Oh my god, I cannot remember the symbols on the
top of my head.
Like...
Every time I look at it, everybody forgot what it looks
like.
Like...
Okay.
Double circle!
And then... Wait, no?
This circle?
This circle.
And then this circle.
And then this?
No, it's one of these circles.
It's...
It's one of these circles.
Okay, it's not that circle.
Maybe it's this circle.
I can't remember the circles.
I already forgot the circles.
I know it's a circle.
Maybe this?
Okay, it's not that circle.
Maybe it's this circle.
Is it this circle?
Wasn't that circle?
yeah i got it i knew i knew it was one of the circles i
fucking knew it god i'm so smart yay
guys i knew it was circle i just can't remember which circle
i go with first try
try I did it wait there's more people where did you come
from why is you still here what the fuck whoa shit where did
those people come from can you really blow up you light it
didn't you light it yeah I was gonna say you should be dead.
Where did you come from?
Alright.
Loot.
Nice.
Are there any more surprise people?
Are there any more?
Ganga, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki has a unique way of pronouncing circle.
It's pretty cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's called the Doki accent.
The Doki scent.
It's called never, like, growing up around the world that
you fucking absorbed every accent possible.
Wait, what is that?
Did I miss something here?
What the fuck is that?
Wait, there were treasure here?
What the fuck?
How did I miss that?
Okay, I guess I go back.
I missed some treasure.
Treasure!
Oh, no, that's a door.
Wait, but what is that over here?
There's, like, treasure right here.
God.
Here?
Can I miss some treasure?
Don't tell me I should have looked up.
Is it up treasure?
It has to be up treasure.
It's, oh, is it this?
There's no way.
Are you treasure?
But you're just a lamp.
Oh no, you're treasure.
There you go.
knew it i knew you were hiding from me okay i'm gonna reload
just in case because the ammo here is so fucking slow hey we
got one of the heads look money is important guys how else
am i gonna keep upgrading my shit guys leon deserves it god
leon deserves it oh my god is there no reverse is there no
oh it's okay i was gonna say i was like where's reverse s
reverse ivy thank you for the five get the shifts thank you
thank you okay we need a i'm gonna go save i don't trust my
stuff i'm gonna go save real fast don't worry guys we will
progress the story it might be an hour later but we will
progress the story do not worry we will meet ashley soon
Eventually, Ashley will be here.
Just trust.
Trust the process.
Okay, we gotta put these two together just in case.
And then, let's see.
We, okay, we need to put this in here too.
Oh, wait, no, I can't combine it because I'm so stupid.
Okay, we need a yellow herb.
Who is Ashley?
We've been stuck on chapter 4 for a while now.
Okay.
Guys, no, we need the loot.
We need the loot so we can upgrade.
It's all about the upgrades.
Think about the bloodline.
Think about it.
Noble, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, think about the bloodline.
How would Leon continue it if he isn't fucking jacked?
Alright, this is it.
Let's go.
this way.
Upgrades, people!
Upgrades!
Raise, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright, here we go.
We have to go.
Uh, wait.
Do the chickens lay new eggs?
Chickens!
Did you guys lay new eggs for me?
Sorry, this is a very important detour.
You won't understand.
Chickens!
What the fuck?
I left you guys there for an hour and you don't lay new eggs
guys You know what that means
Yeah Chickens you lay an egg right now.
Okay, you know what if you don't lay an egg If you don't
lay.
Oh shit.
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna go now Hey I
They were too...
Look.
Look, they called my bluff, guys.
They called my bluff.
What could I do?
They knew I was bluffing.
They knew.
What could I have done?
I can't believe they knew.
You should not be named.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At this rate, I will risk.
You know what?
That'd be more convenient for me if she does rescue herself.
I you know I would like be okay with that you know I'd be
like 100% okay with that if she wants to rescue herself like
then I can just go home like why the fuck would why would I
keep going I rather just go home I want to where is this
where is this place I already go back go back and go home
like why would I want to be in Europe like what the fuck
right now like look at what's going on in europe right now
like taxes man bacon thank you for the magenta soup but
thank you thank you by the time you find ashley you can use
this for retirement funds they give me the magenta soup but
they thank you uh all right um backwards three backwards
three was that is that it is that all the numbers all i see
is backwards three is there more stuff over there i can't
tell that is that symbol over there
oh that whatever that is anymore all this yellow is like not
very very hard to see uh amber alert sammy thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you Thank you.
Ashley Graham, Caucasian female, last scene, Resident Evil
4.
Look, I am trying my best here.
Wait, there's so many backwards three.
Which is the right backwards three?
There's more backwards three to this?
How do I piece the backwards three together?
What?
Okay, wait, I'm going to get on our boat, clearly.
This is the second floor.
Well, I can't fucking go through there.
How the fuck do I go to the second floor?
Guys, I figured it out.
Guys, I did it.
I figured out how to get to the second floor.
Okay.
Backwards three and this line.
Bro, I'm just gonna draw this.
Fuck this.
Bro.
Okay, I can't...
I'm too lazy to get pieces.
paper okay chat you're gonna help me remember this okay um
three people sitting in a group three people sitting in a
group backwards three with a little bump backwards three and
with a little bump what's the third one wait what's the
second but what's the second one then okay this is locked
one open okay okay we got two three fish kissing wait that's
a great one Three fishies kissing.
Backwards three with a little bump.
Needs to go see a doctor.
Backwards three that needs to see a doctor.
On the ladder.
Oh, tidal waves.
Okay, we got this.
We got this.
We are not brute forcing.
Tidal waves.
Backwards three that needs to see a doctor.
And then three fish kissing.
Yay!
We did it!
Nice.
Oh, and there's money.
I like money.
Okay, and then we grab that.
Oh my god, there's the hexagon!
Leon has to hurry according to Chris.
Claire is hitting on me.
Rod Trigo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, nice.
Now we got the key.
Oh, hey, and then there's the...
Stab!
Nice, we got the ruby.
There you go.
I can go through this door for no reason.
All right, nice.
Yay!
All right, this was definitely much more chill than the
other one.
That was definitely much more chill.
All right, we go...
Nice, $100.
Bam!
All right, we need to go see the fish.
We have all the hexagon pieces.
now actually don't worry we're almost done here Ashley
Ashley do not worry Leon is almost done exploring look look
he's young okay he's young and he has to like explore he's
not gonna be like mid 20s forever young 20 I don't know
early 20s?
Alright, nice.
Now I can do it a puzzle!
Okay, how do I do it with a puzzle?
Okay.
What is this?
Is this... like that?
Oh, done.
Okay.
That was easy.
Deprived Idol?
What's that for?
What the fuck is that for?
How old is Leon?
Anyway.
i did it but what do i do with this what do i what do i what
do i uh
is that money i like money all right here we go we got it
yay okay now now we go back to the merchant oh is it
treasure nice guys i found this historical this historical
artifact this time the british museum it it's good to know
leon is just like the british museum all right here you go
why can't you bro what the fuck there you go i was gonna say
like what the fuck did i park it I mean, it is, you're...
Alright, here we go.
Let's see.
I sell it?
I can!
An eerie statue made of gold!
Hello!
Oh my god, this like, clearly an historical artifact made
hundreds and thousands of years ago.
Well, time to sell it.
You're welcome.
Let's see.
We gotta save our game.
Just in case.
Alright.
Shadow Knight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just looked it up.
Leon is 27 in Resident Evil 4.
And British the idol.
Oh dear.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What?
It's $15,000 runies?
Let's fucking go.
Okay.
It's alright.
If they really want it back, they'll just, they'll just buy
it.
If they really want back their artifact, they'll just buy it
back.
They clearly don't care because it wasn't protected.
Guys, that was sarcasm.
Before anybody tries to cancel me for this, that was a joke.
That was a joke before anyone tries to cancel me.
okay let's see um all right we gotta go back and place the
heads okay all right here we go uh all right time to put the
heads in the hands they're gonna firmly grasp it oddball
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh the
adventures of indiana Doki the quest for more money I'm just
like Indiana Jones but instead of returning the artifacts I
take it back and sell it so like the good one the relatable
Jones all right church insignia this what do I do with this
with a quest item I have the church insignia now
Condor or Wanderous I found the key to the church Copy that
Now go get baby eagle Right No time to chat I'm going in Now
I should go get Ashley Oh my god It's Ashley time Finally
After trying to get rich Now it's Ashley time Alright How do
I get back to the church though?
How?
How do I get there?
Here?
how tough to get to church because I need help how do we go
back to the church
okay actually okay where's the okay where's the fish guys
where's the lunker lunker fish find from the merchants area
oh wait that's how we get back to the church the first
treasure Okay, but how do we get to the boat house?
Take the boat house.
Oh, that's the boat house?
There's a fish there?
Okay.
Alright, we go to get the fish.
We'll do it.
Like my Oshi, Mr. Crab, says Money.
Alright, here.
Here we go.
Alright, let's see.
There he is!
Can I...
Bro, there he is!
Alright, he's gonna walk into my spear right here.
Boom!
What the fuck?
What fish is this?
Oh, there we go.
Nice, I did it.
Okay, give me a sec.
I need it.
I'm circling around.
Give me a sec.
Where did the fish go?
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
Oh, it's just a bass.
It's too small.
Wait, how big are these fishes supposed to be?
How big are these fishes supposed to be?
It's just dredge time.
Whoa, that's a big fish!
Okay, now I know.
Now I know how big the fish is.
supposed to be guys i have a size of reference now oh god
okay good good that's good i did that so okay there we go
now we know double tap just in case yeah it's supposed to be
that big nice yay oh come on man okay um we gotta figure we
gotta we gotta fucking
All right, we have to go to the merchant anyway.
All right, here we go.
I can't believe it.
An hour and 20 minutes, and now we're progressing the story.
Now, now we're progressing.
All right, here we go.
just what do you mean by that what do you mean by the first
fish is you in one way in in what way what's your name who
says that who said that oh yeah what do you mean by this
all right let's sell this fish all right it's only five
thousand it was a Big fish!
It's all rubbish.
It makes no difference.
The price.
Okay, here we go.
That's our choice.
Damn.
We did it!
Yeah!
You've proven yourself.
You're an explosive friend.
Look, he made that comment.
I'm just curious what he meant.
I want to take care of any leftover errands before going
this way.
Be ashamed to live the rest of your life.
I already did everything.
Oh, it's like a hint to be like this is.
You won't come back here.
Okay.
I think we're good.
I think we did everything.
I mean, we got so many upgrades.
I got, I did, I swear, I did like 10 plus saves just in this
one area.
Uh...
Is this how we go back?
Is this the door?
Oh, wait, I missed out on some resources.
Okay, we go through here.
Boop!
all right here we go up we go all right let's see we're
missing some resources here where is it though it's like
here somewhere oh there it is okay i found it that's good we
needed that too nice we didn't see i forgot about this nice
money okay that means i can put gems in here.
Wait.
Three of the same?
That's three of the same.
1.4.
Yes!
Okay.
I got this.
Boop.
Nice.
That is 21,000.
Alright, we're going back down.
Guys, this is important.
Wait, how do I... I'm so lost.
Which way?
So this way?
Guys, this is important!
hello i'm back i'm back you thought i was gonna go i got
some more stuff to sell okay now i'm good now i'm done okay
now we progress this is it progression time now we progress
the story I need to craft some fucking shotgun ammo.
We are so lacking in that right now.
Where's... Now we progress.
God, this is so dark sometimes.
Okay, this way, query, and then we go around.
God, it's so far.
Where's my quick travel?
Where's my fast pass?
Oh, shit!
Oh, it's a trolley!
It's time to at all.
Oh, God.
This is it.
They gotta keep crawling.
Guys, this is it, guys.
This is what the rifle was for!
This is it!
Oh, my God.
Please.
Oh You got worms too?
Oh, he does.
Oh, what?
Why can't I run from that?
Oh my god, they gotta have so much eggs.
It's egg time.
I have the reload.
Sir, please wait.
Please wait.
Yes.
Woo!
the good wall
oh I could have done a quick time event with that I I'm
doing good wall nice don't kill him don't kill no
oh god oh god I didn't realize I could wait what is that it
good boy good boy oh god oh god oh god oh yeah oh yeah He
wants to run.
Give me a sec.
Yes!
Large boy!
Bro, what?
That's it?
I told you.
Rifle is for bosses only.
That's almost a pancake.
This is why I didn't use my rifle.
Let's get to that church.
Rifle is for bosses only.
chat.
Where's the good wolf?
Where'd the good wolf go?
Oh shit.
Nice loot.
Alright.
Boop.
Nice.
Alright.
We need more rifle ammo though.
We are actually lacking now in the rifle department.
Okay.
We got we gotta like save up for this.
His mission is done.
Thank you.
finally we have the good wolf we waited so long for him to
show up nice oh my god there's so much kitchen knife too oh
my god i'm raining in fucking ammo jesus christ this is a
mess now this is actually a mess to look at now um well we
can come on this to make the super potions um oh my god bro
this hurts to look at
Go into his dead.
Oh, yeah, his little home.
There must be stuff in here, right?
Wait, is this like...
Wait, did I come from here?
No, I came from here.
Where is your house?
Is it here?
Yeah, this is where you live, right?
Six months.
Its teeth have only just come through, but it shows
everything within it.
reached into his mouth.
It can't walk yet, but it swallowed a dog hole.
Nine months, it already towers over me, but it keeps
growing.
The town hall can no longer contain it.
Ten months, it keeps growing.
Even after moving to the quarry, it can devour a whole cow
in only three days.
It can swing our largest pig ass as if it were a twig.
One of the men of the village was almost eaten today, it's
not getting enough food 17 months there are only a few cows
left now at this rate the whole village will starve we
summoned help from the castle and had them put the beast to
sleep with incantation hopefully it won't wait for a long
time that sucks man you spent all this time this is a tiny
house this is a really tiny house that poor fucking troll oh
my god Wait, if you had leftover meat, how are you starving?
You literally had meat here.
Oh my god.
Hello, troll.
I didn't need to pay the toll.
Wait, is there anything else I missed?
I think I got everything, right?
Poor guy.
What?
Dog!
Hello, dog.
Thanks, bud.
Thank you for your service.
here let us let us cut our palms and shake our hands so we
can be blood brothers
what it's a blood pack he did a good job i'm just trying to
do a blood pack with him Where the fuck do I go?
This way?
Oh, where's my flashlight?
Alright, here you go.
Give him an A.
You cannot pet the dog.
9 out of 10.
I can't believe it.
I can't pet the fucking dog.
9 out of 10.
What's the point?
What the fuck is the point?
You can't pet the dog.
Alright, this way.
okay i have so much ammo for my handgun now god i hope
ashley does never shows up oh god evil dog you know what
evil dog goodbye evil dog goodbye jesus this gun is so
strong now all right we gotta go to the church it's church
time guys have any confessions to make oh wait Let me
actually, let me go save my game.
I forgot there's like a hole here.
Here, right?
Here.
Yeah, there's a safe spot here.
Alright, save the game first before we do anything.
Before we, I don't want to kill the troll again.
Alright.
Game breaking bug can't pet the dog.
What's the point?
I would like to return this game.
Let's see.
Yeah, but I can't do anything with that.
It's a locked drawer.
Here we go.
I have the thing.
We're progressing the story.
Nice.
This is a well-designed church.
This is where all the villagers' money went into.
Hello!
I am...
It's this puzzle!
I know this puzzle.
We have to align this thing.
Look for Ashley in the church.
Uh...
I got a key.
Wait, I can unlock the door.
Okay.
Ashley?
Puzzle time.
Okay.
Wait, but what about the other button?
Is there another button?
Oh, maybe the... Oh, wait.
Vaults.
What the fuck?
I don't have an arrow.
I don't have a thing there.
Do I need to...
Do I need to find the other button?
I don't remember.
Oh, hey.
Why are these...
I like how they're all the ammo I don't need.
I don't have any of those guns!
Where are you trying to say?
Oh, there you go.
There's the blue dial.
Nice.
There it is.
What are you trying to say, man?
Okay, we're gonna put this here.
God damn it.
I don't have any.
The merch is not near me.
Okay, we're gonna figure this out.
We need to clean this up.
Okay, and then we'll put that.
definitely not clean okay there we go perfect we need like
one more so i can craft more rifle ammo and then we should
be good and then everything will be okay this might not look
very pretty but everything will be okay soon everything will
be okay soon okay bam hey uh i need to remember how to do
this uh clearly not like that no oh here okay we got that
and then oh this puzzle is easy so it's as easy as the
fucking the other puzzle with the circles there for babies
nice oh that's so pretty all right actually we're finally
gonna find you It's time, Ashley.
Alright, Ashley.
Ashley.
You in there?
Ashley!
Oh!
Nice.
Okay, now we can craft the rifle.
Okay, this feels a lot better.
This looks a little bit better.
Okay.
This looks a bit better!
Okay guys, it looks It looks less fucked up Okay, but what
if I just put all of this below here And I put this here And
then there, there you go Efficiency We're not gonna eat the
eggs, I'm full HP There's no point There's no point to eat
the eggs when you're full HP Guys
I'm not trying to make sure I don't Oh hey, there's Ashley's
phone
okay okay there's nothing here so he's she's behind this
door Ashley Ashley you here are you in here oh shit oh right
it's not a phase Leon oh my god
I think I was like, oh, you picked that up, bitch.
What is that?
Over there?
I see you there.
The last lambs are a skit.
They're singing.
Oh, fuck.
Guys, guys, I just need a no, guys.
Does it end?
Does the wave end?
Because if it does, I'm just gonna kill all of them.
Oh my god, we finally completed the chapter!
Yay!
it does I'm gonna kill all of them I'm not gonna steal
because I have enough ammo to do this clearly it will
everything has an end good that's all that matters alright
it's time we have to we have too much inventory space what
What do we do?
We kill all of them, Ashley.
We're going to do a doki-style brute force it until they're
all dead.
God, we don't have such an ugly skin.
It makes me feel less bad.
When she dies, it makes me feel less horrible.
Alright.
All right, let's get the hell out of here.
Okay, we can get up here.
We go up here and then we kill them all.
Go, Ashley.
Okay.
Go, Ashley, go.
Jesus Christ, it's just so...
Such an ugly outfit.
Okay, Ashley, you stay here and I'm gonna shoot everything.
Okay.
dude okay ashley you stay here and i'm gonna shoot
everything ashley
okay all right there we go now she's safe
hurry up we have so much ammo we can do this oh oh okay all
right let's just get that out of the way All right,
reloading.
Wait, where is he going?
Hello, I'm over here.
Hello.
Nice.
Is she gonna turn?
Wait, they don't even have loot.
What the fuck?
They don't even have loot?
Bro, this
bro!
They don't even have loot!
It's supposed to be...
yeah what's the point oh my god actually i don't want to
look at you
oh look i i don't get punished because there was ammo here
anyway oh my god i thought i could have got free loot this
is so unfair who was a poor i've just killed not so innocent
elderly.
Alright, here we go.
I can't get over this outfit.
Damn, it's really something.
Sweet soul.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Stay there.
Just don't leave.
I can't look at her.
Make it stop.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't keep calling Ashley's outfit ugly is breaking my heart
no
what about the makeup okay you stay here um i can't no she
follows me forever okay i've secured baby eagle i got baby
eagle she's right here sure i'll dispatch a chopper asap
the weather is getting worse can you not just send a
helicopter here can you send a helicopter here head for the
extraction point jesus christ it's all the way okay we're
clearly not gonna well knowing by this we're gonna get like
kidnapped somewhere here all right actually i'm gonna make
you like stay somewhere very close by okay ashley you are
going to okay i'm just
all right here we go okay ashley your job okay tight and
loose switch between tight ash will stick close while you
can see me effective when running past enemies okay switch
ash will hang behind okay that will hang what the fuck
behind leon while in loose her this can help her avoid
enemies attack okay i'm actually close behind while in tight
formation this can be effective Blash you.
Okay.
How do I make her stay?
Stay.
Where am I?
Spread out.
Okay.
On me.
Just spread out.
Okay, spread out.
Give me space.
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
We're just... Get behind me.
What is wrong with these people?
I don't know, but I don't think they like that I'm fucking
shooting them.
I think that was it.
Oh, that is a lot.
Okay, let me reload.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
This is where things get spicy.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
It's fine.
Thick thighs.
Save lives.
Ashley, and this is why you gotta buff up your thighs.
Oh, Ashley!
Stay behind me!
Ashley, no!
Oh!
Esmer!
I said stay behind me!
That is not tight!
Thank you.
Oh my God, thank God.
Oh, fuck, this is what eggs are for.
This is what eggs are for.
Guys, I have no time!
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh
god, oh god, please, I'm reloading.
Are you okay?
Alright, nice.
Okay, we're fine.
Alright.
Get the fuck up.
Okay, we're fine.
Just stay in here.
I'm going to open this drawer.
Okay, we got the...
We're going to save our game now.
We're going to save...
Actually, please afford our love.
Oh, God.
Where is the stay here command?
I thought this...
I...
Ochi, Resident Evil 4 had stay here.
This is what all the eggs were for.
thank fucking god for the eggs okay we're gonna put this
here all right she is not she was in the original the
original let me say stay here okay let's see do i have
enough to make more shotgun ammo because that is what we
need right now craft oh thank god we had to okay there you
go thank god okay Oh, she's a rebel now.
Bro, fucking Ashley, man.
Stay behind me!
Where?
I hear some noise.
Wait, there's ammo here, though.
Time to make some noise.
Wait, what?
Here we go.
Oh, I couldn't run in there in time.
Oh, nice thing guy.
Alright, I need you to die a bit faster so I can take your
loot.
Nice, gunpowder.
That is good.
Stay behind me, Ashley!
Behind!
Please, please, behind!
there okay nice the merchants here oh thank god oh thank god
thank you for the money oh you do i need we're the new items
oh it's just not new items i had all of these what the fuck
do you mean liar they're the same thing okay let's see we're
gonna have to sell our like one of our flash grenades we
have way too much we were gonna we have we have way okay
we're sell the bolts because we are not running any bolts
and we are not running submachine gun we're not running
submachine gun we have everything we need we have ammo we
have we have look we just have too much flashes we had too
many we just have too many okay i just don't have enough
space guys had we just didn't have a lot of space if it was
worth it worth the exchange look look how much better my
inventory is now chat like it was a pro it was turning into
a problem i was becoming a hoarder and that's bad honestly
like it started getting a little too messy guys like it
started Okay, here we go.
Like, it was starting to become a really bad big problem.
Alright, save.
Okay, Ashley, here we go.
Last one, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think he's going to get rid of the wild dog that's been
roaming up.
Which one?
There were so many.
There's so many wild dogs.
Which one?
Which one are they talking about?
There's like so many.
Don't tell me they're fucking bigger than before.
The super duper dog.
Oh no.
I have Ashley here.
Sorry, we need to keep moving.
I mean, you can.
You don't stay with the merchant.
Do I need to reload my gun?
No, I don't.
Okay, I just have to be sure.
Dad, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
hate the smg it's a great gun well the pistol is just faster
i just have to hit the headshot which i totally do because
i'm a gamer i just think the pistol is just faster
i missed the stay here command was right about the weather
okay is there an end guys i need to know is there an end to
these guys would i miss the bearer there's a oh there it is
like right friend of me yes okay it's time it's time guys
there is an end every time there's an end i fight i fight if
there's an end oh fuck okay oh my god ashley no stay behind
ashley i said tight Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, nice.
We can guard the window.
Guys, we'll just guard the window.
We'll just guard the window.
Oh my god!
Okay, we're fucking throwing this.
Christy, son of a bitch.
Okay.
Guys, and that is how you guard the window.
Guys, the window.
The window is the strat.
They always have to come to the window.
There we go.
Just guard the window.
Nice.
A power of the window!
There we go.
Is that everybody?
There.
Okay, now that's not cool, man.
Okay, I know you're gonna pop up now.
Alright, nice.
Are you dead?
I can't tell.
The window is so dark!
Window!
Okay, Ashley.
This is why...
This is why I have the cheese.
It's because of you
Actually, this is your fault.
I have the cheese even harder because of you Are they done
Okay, are they all dead?
I've killed a lot All right, no, I don't have window anymore
if I have to do this
The window MVP Oh my god.
Actually, shut the fuck up.
I had I you're the you're you're a problem.
You're a problem right now
Okay, let's see oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh my inventory is so empty now
Okay, let's see all right oh we can finally get this loot
Ashley are they all dead have we windowed enough no I hear
one guy I hear him lurking all right there you go wait Wait,
what the fuck?
Where is he going?
Does he know I'm here?
Does this man know I'm here?
I don't know if he knows.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
Oh my god!
Okay!
Alright.
No, I don't think he still knows, guys.
It's okay.
We can kill him all the way here.
He still doesn't know he's walking back.
He's walking back.
Guys, I don't think he knows.
He's walking backwards.
We're fine.
Actually, cover your ears.
I think he can make this shot.
We're not gonna...
It was a waste of my ammo.
Okay.
It should be this, right?
Wait, where is the...
Oh, no.
It's the door behind us.
Alright.
It's right here.
Nice.
Ashley, come over here.
I need this loot.
This is exactly why I needed you here.
This is the most important.
This is your purpose.
I need you to open it from the other side.
This is your entire purpose to open that one door for me.
Oh,
Ashley.
Okay.
Nice.
Thank you.
I've always wanted to be in this room.
Alright, now you can leave.
Oh, what's this?
The elegant vanguard.
Oh my god.
okay then lay I can put the two yellow stones in oh my god
how much money is it 22,000 actually good good job girl you
were worth it you were worth babysitting get paid $5 to
babysit get $22,000 back profit all right we gotta kill that
one guy over here right okay let's see I'm gonna make sure
like all the people here are dead before i do any of this
like i hear noises but i don't know if it's like coming from
like where is that coming from inside is there somebody
inside i hear the i hear like upies or upies upies where is
that coming from Who's calling for upies right now?
Okay, we go up.
Who wants upies?
You hear that?
They keep calling for upies.
Him, right?
Isn't this guy?
Oh, it's him!
He wanted upies!
I fucking knew it!
Oh, fuck.
Oh fuck.
No!
Okay.
Alright.
He fucking scared me.
Alright, we got him.
It's fine.
We still have the eggs.
Actually, I don't even need to heal.
There we go, we're fine.
From 80 bullets to 20... 20 bullets.
It was worth it.
I wonder if I didn't... if I should...
I feel like they'd be like empty because I looted this area.
already yeah yeah i needed this all right here we go they're
all dead we did it mayor's house before you progress where's
the mayor's house here guys i don't know where the fucking
mayor lives like oh here okay but what do i get guys but
what do i get though you gotta convince me here how much
money a dwarf okay oh I have Ashley though guys but what if
I die I have to deal with Ashley okay now we're talking
business okay guys i'm the deal with ashley though it's
worth the risk it's worth the ashley risk okay i'm gonna go
save my game then
guys i'm gonna go save my game there's no way actually
you're coming with me we're saving our game i killed so many
people with a window i actually you are not worth it girl
you're absolutely not worth it all right here we go okay you
have the stench of battle on you man all right here we go oh
where did actually go there she is okay all right please
stay behind me actually Okay, you know what?
You guys were right.
I missed OG Ashley.
This Ashley fucking sucks.
Like, this Ashley is terrible.
At least OG Ashley, if I tell her to stay, she stays.
This Ashley does not stay.
This Ashley does not know the concept of please stand back.
I have a gun.
Okay.
It should be this way.
Back we go.
Oh.
Can I trade for OG, Ashley?
Oh my god.
Oh, can I bring my shotgun just in case we see the super
dog?
Just in case super dog decides to show up.
Super dog?
Super dog.
We all want to go home, Ashley, but here we are.
Where are you?
We're super dog.
I don't like that.
It started making the ambience noise.
Super dog?
Is Super dog here?
Super dog.
Why is there creepy ambience?
Where's that treasure?
Is that... Oh, the savage mud.
Okay, Super dog is here.
Alright, Super dog.
Super dog is apparently here now.
super dog in the room with us?
Super dog?
Where are you?
Is the treasure, like, upstairs?
Because I don't remember.
Super dog?
Alright, time to save.
Okay.
Super dog, I have a shotgun.
I have a treat for you!
Where's Superdog?
I forgot where the treasure is.
Oh, it's a collapsible ladder!
This is where Superdog is!
Got it.
Alright, here you go.
Alright, nice.
Lime up.
It's called treasure.
okay all the men cheered and then everyone clapped all the
men cheered when they heard the boat as it raced across the
surface of the water that magnificent oil will surely help
us catch fish easier than ever before the ironworks was only
built a year ago but this has already merged well with the
village our sickles and knives shine like never before the
two fish we got from the deal will eat almost anything and
are breeding well.
The fish farm in the swamp is also making excellent
progress.
During the day, I teach literacy and mathematics to the
children.
Every evening, I dine with a single family to hear their
grievances and recent gossip.
All under the roof of this home we built.
Since I opened up the village to the outside, we have
prospered and the people are happier.
Smiles have even started to appear on their faces.
group of black-robed people descended upon the village
within the castle and raised an ominous flag with
spider-like insignia upon him after preaching about
salvation and forgiveness they injected us with something
they claim will cure us with madness can they be trusted i
don't know if a fucking guy came from a castle and injected
you with something i don't know do you trust that and that
really be trusted oh that's him is that a priest Oh,
that's...
What is that?
Watch over the village in my stead, and my smiles always
find you in photographs.
That little bit.
Oh.
Yes, he shouldn't.
Oh, hey, there's a...
Oh.
Nice.
Alright.
Reload.
Okay, what's this photo?
Is this lore?
The long-awaited iron works.
Oh, this is lore.
Boop.
Money.
Did I miss anything?
Oh, there's more, Lord.
The elder entrusted the village to me today.
He told me I can learn my duties as I go.
I'll start by keeping a record of the village.
There's so many words I cannot write.
But the elder encouraged me.
I will do my best.
There is a young boy who lives in a cabin by the lake with
his grandfather.
It seems that his mother was called to heaven upon his
birth.
His grandfather doesn't talk much, The lad is very bright
and spirited.
He told me a story about a knight who rides a donkey again
today.
The boy's grandfather has fallen ill.
His condition worsens every day.
The boy worries terribly about him, and there are murmurs of
a madness among the villagers.
As I took my leave, the old man pulled me aside and said, If
anything happens, you know what to do.
I can only nod in response.
It was a terrible night.
around the cabin and watched as it burned to the ground.
The boy looked on without saying a word.
Even as dawn broke, he didn't move a muscle.
The next day, he was gone.
And then everyone clapped.
I missed a box over there?
Okay, let me check where it is.
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Got an empty camera.
What the fuck do I do with that?
Oh, this is the boy in his family.
That's him.
Wait, is that going to be the short guy in the later on?
Did he grow up to be evil?
Did you grow up to be evil, little boy?
Alright.
Apparently you have to be spread out right now because of
the wolf.
Alright, what do you got here?
Where's the evil wolf?
I'm gonna say that.
I know the evil wolf is gonna fucking come out and, like,
bite me or some shit.
Zonderman.
You 1% seem the type to skip the lore.
What the heck is happening?
What do you mean?
I always read the lore.
It's the lore.
It's the lore pause.
The lore always gives us the fucking pauses.
It's the safe space.
okay guys where's the evil dog we're super dog like this is
very important where the fuck is super dog the lord breaks
yeah okay we're gonna save our game just in case where
outside the other outside this outside is super dog on this
side Super dog.
Super dog, are you here?
Super dog!
Oh, I hear him.
I hear super dog.
He's on the other side!
What the fuck he's on the other side?
Super dog's on the other side.
Where did he get there?
I heard him, he barked.
Super dog barked.
But it wasn't like the scary bark.
He just went, Wait, I missed the treasure.
Okay, guys, where's the treasure again?
I already forgot.
I forgot.
Is that on the first floor or the second floor?
Oh, there it is.
Alright, I got it.
I know I missed something here.
Okay.
Super dog, where are you?
There you are!
Get over here!
Open the door!
Wait, can I just shoot you from here?
Super dog, come back!
Super dog!
Where did you go?
Where did he go?
Where the fuck did he go?
Where are you?
Super dog?
Big!
This is super duper dog!
Oh my god, super duper dog can dodge.
Super duper dog can dodge.
What the fuck is wrong with this dog?
Sab!
goodbye super duper dog what the fuck I said goodbye I said
goodbye what do you mean what do you mean what
is wrong with super duper dog oh my god Jesus Christ He said
no.
I should have used the sniper jam.
Oh my god.
That shit was scary.
He really was the super dog.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know how I lived there.
She screamed Leon.
I was like, what?
Oh, yeah, I did.
I definitely did.
There's no super dog.
No, I can possibly say.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Jesus Christ.
Got a selection of good things on sale.
Like, there's nothing worth it.
Nothing worth it.
All right, we're going to sell that.
Oh, wait, no, I can sell these two.
Okay.
Anti-camera, we got that.
Nice.
Okay.
Is it worth buying the rocket launcher or nah?
Is it worth it?
is it is it worth it guys or nah nah okay no okay nah okay
apparently some people like no and some people like nah but
i have i have my rifle my rifle though okay we'll trade for
the mask and then we can sell do i have enough though for it
it is is a circle round okay i don't have enough round stuff
for that okay we're gonna find more jewels later all right
man Luke I almost missed out on oh wait there's more money
cuz some more stuff okay nice okay now now we save again now
we save again guys don't work we will we will get to another
I swear we will get to another chapter
guys don't worry we will get to another chapter soon guys do
not worry did you max out i'm pretty sure i maxed it out
let's check uh yeah everything's max everything that matters
maxed out um i might as well max out the shock no will i be
finding a better shotgun soon
to get a better shotgun soon or should we just um yeah when
what chapter yes very soon okay all right i won't upgrade it
i don't want to waste money then i'll just upgrade the knife
like might as well i'm gonna fix the knife all right there
you go as long as we max out the knife it's fine i don't
need the better rate of fire honestly the rate of fire is
like um i like someone's like it's next soon that's true
true that is so true it's not gonna be soon all right here
you gonna finally go up oh fuck it's this way come on all
right let's go how do we get up top again.
Oh, ladder.
Here we go.
I remember I like ran for this one.
I didn't kill everybody.
This time I killed everyone.
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
I've learned.
There we go.
There are more people?
Oh, there's more people.
Okay, that's fine.
We have ammo here.
Where are they?
Oh, you want to dodge?
Don't worry.
Oh, oh, oh god.
Kick!
Nice.
Okay, sap!
No, no, no, no!
No, I couldn't get the sap!
No!
Ashley!
Ashton!
I'm so sorry, but I didn't get the stab in time!
No, my shotgun.
Oh my god.
I don't know what happened!
The stab didn't show up!
Okay.
What the fuck happened?
My shotgun, Emu!
Oh, my shotgun, Emu!
No!
A beautiful shotgun ammo.
What the fuck is that?
Is that the cow?
That's the strongman!
This is what the rifle is for.
Nice, he's dead.
Alright.
There we go.
I mean, the cows are still alive.
Good for them.
The cows are still fucking tanking it.
Okay, we're gonna be living in poverty soon.
Remember when we had like 80 at...
How?
How the fuck?
That was point blank.
Guys, remember when we had 80 bullets?
I remember.
How?
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Please.
Please give me a chance to melee.
Okay, there you go.
Please.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Thank God.
Everything is fine.
I have the key.
Money.
Oh, sorry.
Did I stab you?
Wait, can I actually hurt her?
Holy shit, we are so fucking poverty right now.
Oh my god.
Okay, maybe...
No, okay, we are so fucking poor.
I need to stop shooting.
We're so poor.
I remember when we used to rule the world.
Hello piggy Hello cow There's like loot here somewhere See
all this Hey, look, I know No, I fucking forgot about this I
didn't I couldn't see I'm so sad.
I'm so fucking sad.
It was so dark guys.
I couldn't see It was so dark.
I couldn't see
It was so dark.
How was I supposed to know?
Okay, we gotta save our game.
Nice.
Alright.
Alright, actually, it's time.
We're a little bit in the poverty line right now, but it's
okay.
Everything will be okay.
you we ain't hurt are you fucking are you fucking kidding me
you fuck what's gonna happen the cow is gonna fucking run
into her again right what's gonna happen are you fucking
it's a cow oh my god are you fucking kidding me actually
please ashley please ashley where is he oh there he is oh my
god that's a damn it actually i can't i can't deal with you
man okay let's see do you have can i not buy ammo from you
this is not fair i should be allowed to you like cause of
death cow okay is there anything else i think i've done
everything i can yeah it's all over it's okay all right
we're gonna go in we're gonna be like below the poverty line
but like god i hope the president pays well I hope he
doesn't just give me a medal.
Oh,
shit, bro!
Major, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wonderful, great entertainment.
Like, every time you have, thank you!
I'm glad you've been enjoying it.
Bro, I don't want the medal of honor, Mr. President.
Just give me a hundred grand.
I'm wondering if it's legal to sell your medal of honor from
the president.
Hello, Luis.
Damn.
You like, cabbed on him.
Hide now.
In that case, here, help me.
Ashley, quick.
Over here.
Yeah, but you don't want to pawn shop it.
You want to put it on online to sell because the pawn shop
will always rip you off If I ever get a medal of honor, make
sure to look at eBay
Look at eBay and wave
Okay all right use
where the fuck do i okay nice okay this is it boom oh where
did you come from
bam oh oh cut oh cut oh god it's the window time it's window
time.
Oh, God.
Reloading!
Yes!
Give me ammo!
Shoot him!
Oh, God.
Kick!
This is a knee time!
Okay, now I have to fucking shortcut this.
Oh, why did I sell?
Why did I sell?
Why did I throw it?
Yeah, nice.
Okay.
Why did I sell My flash.
Wait, I got loot here.
Go, Lewis!
Go!
I'm just grabbing some ammo!
Boom!
Oh, shit.
That's not what I wanted.
Oh, God.
I need to reload.
Lewis, that's a fucking barrel!
Okay, it's okay.
Kick!
Oh, not good.
Not good.
he knew us give me ammo for this no it's only handgun only
it's handguns only apparently it's handguns only apparently
oh god more wooden planks nice
it's okay i'm gonna reinforce this nice all right now he can
only go one way where did he come from
okay oh shit yes
Oh, no, he has ladder!
Where are you gonna come from?
The stairs?
Oh, shit, okay.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm going up.
Leon, why?
Why did you pause?
Oh!
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Ulyss.
Oh, shit!
Okay, this is time for Heel's time.
This is good time for Heel's time.
This is Oh, it's time Oh shit, it's time.
I don't remember my shortcut.
I don't remember my shortcut bindings Ah, this is it Ah,
fuck, okay, let me I'm trying Equip boom If you die, it's
not my fault
Okay all right there you go it's fine the eggs this is why
we have the eggs it's daytime if you die it's not my fault
okay okay it's fine nice there you go please Oh, bless!
Oh, God.
A little busy at the moment.
Yes, I am very busy.
So much for service for this matter, huh?
Gotta guess what?
It's worth just as well.
Oh, God.
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
He one-shots me!
What is my egg?
bros give me the ammo louis if you die i'm sorry i'm so
sorry if you die oh god oh god oh god okay we're fine we're
fine oh thank you holy shit ashley door saved me the The
moment I saw the axe come straight to me, I was like, this
is the moment.
The fuck, holy shit.
Gosh, it was good timing.
Good timing.
The clutch.
Finally, Ashley.
did something useful bro where you oh because they injected
her with stuff saved by the plot the moment i saw the axe i
knew is caused by something called the plaga the plaga okay
you saw those people right but you have the same thing
inside you The same thing that made them like that.
Wait, we're gonna turn like them?
Yes, we're just experiencing these symptoms.
They're only the beginning.
I don't want to become like them.
You are, well, lucky.
Wait, how so?
You see, at this early stage, the parasite, the plaga.
It is possible to remove it with the surgical procedure.
And all you need is some know-how.
And oh, yeah, the right equipment.
Wait, do you know how?
No worries.
See, I have a kitchen knife.
But you're going to have to trust me.
I have a kitchen knife.
Would this help?
Great.
We're partners then.
Hey, why are you...
I'm so thankful that you welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Because it makes me feel better.
Let's leave it at that.
We'll contact you later.
Wait, what?
He's just gonna leave?
it's just gonna leave me like that oh my god we've made it
to another chapter guys we're doing it we're fucking i'm
gonna save it right here we're fucking doing it we actually
made it to another chapter
goodbye lewis goodbye wait we're gonna see more i saw him
leave
Ada?
I do.
The kind you like.
Now where's the Amber?
Unfortunately, it's not on me at the moment.
And you really should be telling me what a good job I did.
Busted my ass and managed to hide it right before I got
caught.
Which is why I'm still alive.
Yeah, I think she's just making him climb that.
get you out of here when you deliver the amber.
No amber, no protection, Louise.
Such a stickler for details, huh, Ada?
Okay, then.
I'll go get it now.
How about that?
And I do have something else I need to get, too.
What?
What is it?
Can I go back?
That sucks.
There was so much loot over there.
No!
Bro,
you barely helped at all.
We could take the boat.
Let's go.
We take that boat.
Look at all this loot!
No!
It's just staring at me!
He's so fucked up.
What's gonna happen to me?
Right now.
Gone forever.
Goodbye loot.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
But I do have all these kitchen knives.
Okay, I'm gonna make, I'm gonna save this.
I need to use my kitchen knives.
Not gonna lie.
Alright.
Do I have enough?
No, I need two more.
I need to save up.
Alright.
See, look.
All those grenades were worth it in the end.
Guys.
They were all worth it.
God, there is way too many kitchen knives.
What am I gonna do with all these kitchen knives, man?
What am I?
My inventory is looking clean all that hoarding gone from
one fucking chapter what is this this is bullshit what's the
point of having money if I can't buy ammo what's the point
why are you giving me more money give me ammo you ever seen
those nasty guns guys of the tentacles on their head not
only are they dangerous but they're a pain to kill they do
have a weakness though they absolutely hate bright lights
like the sun that's why you won't see them during oh thank
you wow thank you i yeah really the riot gun oh shit is this
a better shotgun Wait, is this the better shotgun?
Okay, I'm going to sell my old shotgun then.
Which one?
I almost sold the rifle.
This is the bad one, right?
Yeah, this is the...
Okay, I'm going to sell the old shotgun.
I don't need you anymore.
Alright, bye.
Rye gun.
Okay, yeah.
real boomstick mate it will reduce your target i'm done
playing with you all right here you go uh then we can
upgrade our good shotgun okay nice and then power nice
that's all we need we just need a full full power and then i
don't really need anything else other and that honestly that
everything else is a waste of money oh the stock wait this
is good okay we're gonna need we're gonna need this and then
i'm gonna grab more gunpowder at this rate like i'm fucking
desperate i'm so desperate okay we're gonna put uh put this
here and then here all right there you go good we're good
yes all right here you go should be good now and then we can
make more ammo for the fucking shotgun okay shotgun shells
we always need ammo for shotgun all right we should be good
now whoop because it gave me rifle they always Give me rifle
out.
They know what I want.
Oh, there's boxes here.
Let's forget.
Thank God it's...
Thank God it's marked yellow.
I'm going to save because I don't want to do that again.
I don't want to do that again.
So I'm going to save just in case.
Alright.
That should be good to go.
Here we go.
Oh, I missed out.
Wait, what?
How is your ammo that I missed out?
I smashed everything.
They're not pressed the F key?
Where the fuck is that one fucking resource?
Oh, it's here!
Oh, it's on the box!
Here we go.
Nice.
There we go.
Enter.
It's okay.
I am will- oh, quietly.
Okay.
Wait, guys.
Does this wait?
end yes okay all right we're not doing it quietly yes but
don't do it what what do you mean Why not?
But like, but I can just kill everybody.
It's more fun.
Yes, but there is a lot.
There can't be that many.
Like, there is always an end.
God, there's no way.
There's no way.
way guys there's always an end oh wait is he turning bro why
is he turning in the middle of this that's not fair actually
you're like you're like being seen by everything bro I oh he
got on the bear trap there's traps here fuck okay I was
traps what how oh okay we don't okay okay guys this is bad
guys it's okay I have one more oh
no no warning no no warning
Actually, I don't know.
You know this.
But there's never a warning.
But we have the stock.
Okay, look, it was worth it.
Guys, it was worth it.
Wait, there's more?
Oh, it's because of Phi Lady!
Alright, nice.
We're Phi.
She has to look up, right?
There you go.
see everything is fine we got our ammo back stealth we i
told you we don't need stealth boom that one grenade saved
our fucking lives there we go thank god for that one need
that i have i'm gonna i'm gonna go back and save
I don't want to do that again but like guys I don't want to
do that again though that's the same what if Ashley just
dies also Gator thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you guys I can't trust Ashley What if she dies?
Chat.
What?
You're going to be responsible if she just dies and I have
to do all of that again.
Oh, I forgot to repair the knife.
Sorry, we're going back.
Sorry, Ashley.
We're going back.
What if she doesn't?
Well, that's not the risk I'm going to take.
It's not even 50-50.
There's more of a chance that she's just going to fucking
die.
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
The weak.
It's the president's daughter.
It doesn't matter how weak she is.
She's the president's daughter.
But...
Okay, I cannot protect stupid.
I can delay it.
But I can't protect it.
What the fuck?
Does Ashley burn?
She doesn't burn.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
She doesn't burn.
That's like...
That's fine.
Alright, nice.
Does she turn?
Well, if she turns, she can't fucking like do the thing.
Oh, she is turning.
Are you serious?
I did.
What, like, what is she gonna do?
Is she gonna drop down?
Yeah, she can't do anything.
Okay, but she's annoying me, so I'm just gonna kill it.
She is annoying, though.
There you go.
Nice.
God, more money that I don't need.
I need fucking loot, not money.
Thank you.
That's what I need.
Alright, I thought you guys said like, it's better if it's
like stealth.
That was like not even that many people.
I think maybe this is where I should stealth.
If there's people here.
Actually, no, I don't need to stealth this.
Wait, am I missing loot behind me?
Oh, I'm not.
Oh, wait, I am.
Wait a minute.
I am missing loot.
Sorry, Ashley.
This is important.
Why did
I come back here?
Why did I come back here?
Why the fuck did I come back?
Nice.
We needed that.
We needed a circular thing.
Up we go.
Boop.
Nice.
Rifle ammo.
I'm fucking...
Are you fucking?
Okay.
That's fine.
Where are all these bear traps coming from?
Where are they all coming from?
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
It just keeps happening.
Here we go.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Okay, there is loot here.
Okay, how do I get up here?
Oh, there it is.
What the fuck?
Bro, okay, don't announce your...
Oh!
Oh, shit!
There we go.
Alright, that's fine.
That is fine.
Do I have another egg?
I do not have another egg.
Okay, we need a yellow herb.
We are...
Okay, I can take this.
It'll be fine.
I can take this.
We don't...
We don't need a worry.
We'll find...
We'll find a yellow herb.
sooner or later.
That's the risk I'm willing.
Okay, maybe not.
The way you're looking at me, Ashley, I don't know if that
is the risk I'm willing to take.
I have so many sprays.
That's fine.
This is fine.
I realize that should not be a risk I should take.
Like thinking about it.
That's not a great idea.
Bro, I haven't even fought like Adam.
Sandler yet.
Where'd I go?
Oh, it's this way.
Like, I haven't fought Adam Sandler, and I don't know if
I'll have the resources for this now.
Because I'm fighting everybody.
Sure is quiet.
Yeah, I don't like that.
It sure is.
Why did you have to say that, Leon?
Why?
Never say it's quiet.
It's never a good sign.
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Welcome, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Okay, we can stealth this.
Right?
Maybe I'll like stab one correctly.
Does he see me?
Guys, I thought he didn't see me.
How was I supposed to know?
I don't know.
There was a...
He could have not seen me.
There could have been a possibility.
Wait, wait, wait.
It could have been possible.
I just wanted to...
No.
Just wanted to test out my theory.
I mean Yellow herb I should have risked it I should have
fucking risked it I could I should have Risked it man All
I'm saying is that MatPat graduated so like We need somebody
to test theories out And I was And I was going to take that
risk Who else would have done it If it wasn't for me Who
else Who else okay nice so true all right nice money
order stay inside go into this locker okay oh my god this is
great i don't have to give a shit about you anymore all
right oh my god thank you thank you you're giving me the one
thing i could ever ask for
Ashley just live in there for now I'll be back after I
finish the game Ashley
don't worry I'll come back for you I promise I definitely
promise I just leave her there like does it really matter
guys what did she open did you open a lot oh no that's the
door i was gonna say ashley what did i tell you about not
opening that locker no of course no i would never leave her
yeah i need to just making sure i got all the loot there's
suspiciously a lot of loot i feel like is this gonna be
another boss fight I feel like I have to run around and
shoot people.
I don't know.
This is, yeah.
This is definitely a run around shooting people.
There is way too many fucking ammo around me.
This is way too suspicious.
Why is there so much ammo?
How do I get to that area?
To here?
There it is.
It's an arena of some kind.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna like be I'm gonna use the bathroom be right
back guys There's no way anybody's gonna attack me right I'm
gonna I'm I cannot risk it The game might be like why is she
standing there for so long What if we like fucking throw
some monsters at her?
I'm gonna use the bathroom I'll be right back
All right guys I'm back Ellen and Luca thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you Okay I'm back all right here
we go time to fight something wait this is not it sorry i
already ran the wrong way where am i oh this way okay time
am i going the right way wait where am i time to fight
something here we go all right oh um that's awkward wait
that is a little awkward wait who is that Wait, wait a
minute.
Wait a minute.
Where?
There's Lou here?
Um...
Oh, no.
Okay, we'll figure this out.
Get in the warehouse.
There's a warehouse?
This?
Is that a house?
There's no doors.
Oh, no.
How am I already lost?
Okay.
Oh, it's here.
Okay, here you go.
Okay.
Where am I yellow paint?
Where's the yellow paint?
How am I supposed to know anything?
Oh, here.
Oh, my God.
There was a door here this entire time.
I can't believe it.
Wait, there's a first aid spray.
It's like I never lost it.
I definitely did not notice that.
Let's see.
Oh, there's a crack.
Oh, chainsaw!
Oh, shit!
Does she die?
Oh, fuck.
Two chainsaw women!
What?
Why did mom let you have two?
Sorry, I didn't realize it was yours.
I didn't realize it was yours.
I am flattered.
What the fuck?
Why did mom let you have two?
Oh god.
What the fuck?
Oh what the fuck I do?
Oh thank you for opening that door.
Now I know why Ashley is gone.
Jesus Christ, okay.
Wait, I hear people behind me.
That's not good.
I don't like it when I hear people behind me.
Oh, God.
Oh, I don't like it when there's two chainsaw women!
It's not hot!
Sometimes, two is two.
many.
It's just, what do you do?
There's too much going on.
There's just too much going on.
It's just too overwhelming.
Wait, where are they?
Where did chainsaw women go?
Bro, what the fuck, Matt?
What the fuck?
I can just keep going backwards.
Like...
Alright, we're just gonna...
Let me feed...
I know my back is clear.
That's the answer.
That's what I...
Do I have nades?
Oh, I did.
Bro, I didn't even know I had nades!
Wait, what?
Are they... Can they just walk away?
Where are they?
They just walked away.
It is
Hello?
Where did they go?
What?
They gave up?
Oh, thank God.
Like, where did they go?
Like, they all just disappeared.
Alright, let's just get rid of him.
Do they drop anything?
Oh, Thank God they do.
Okay, it's worth killing them.
I just need to know where chainsaw women.
Where the chainsaw women go.
Where are they?
Oh!
Knock right now!
Holy shit!
Ask and ye shall receive.
Alright, there we go.
Whoa, shit.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Melee, melee, melee!
Oh my god, he's still alive.
There you go.
Yeah, but I got chainsaw women!
Do they actually keep coming?
Wait, do they actually?
Do they...
Is this infinite?
The most important question!
all right goodbye goodbye oh thank god there's always an end
oh thank god there's always an end guys there's always an
end don't worry oh my god chop chop chop no it makes me
happy what the fuck Okay, it doesn't chop him, but it chops
you.
That's fine.
Where's the gun at?
It's okay, there's ammo right there.
That's fine.
Thank God there's always an end.
Thank fucking God.
Ashley?
Who told you to get out of the locker?
Who told you?
Because it's not me.
I know for sure.
was not me.
Ashley, get back in that locker, Ashley.
Get back.
Go back into that locker.
Leon did not say get out.
Go back in here.
I know there was a locker here.
Ashley, get...
Oh my god.
No!
I can't keep you here forever?
Ashley, Why do you do this?
Do you hate me, Ashley?
Ashley, I only had one simple request and it's for you to
live in that locker until I was done.
Do you hate me, Ashley?
Ashley, I'm not gaslighting you.
Do you just hate me?
Alright, here we go.
The locker is your home now, Ashley.
Never leave.
Bro, what?
Bro, Leon!
Bro!
Bro, what the fuck, Leon?
That is inappropriate.
I wonder if I can craft more rifle.
Okay, I need two more.
I feel like I definitely need more rifle.
Okay, let me put some of this.
away and then oh wait I'm gonna put this here actually yeah
this is like a mess again but that's okay
all right nice map updated here we go gotta make sure
everything is reloaded right Jesus Christ the objective is
all the way there oh my god I'd be like and they have to go
okay that's That is a lot of walking.
And a lot of shooting.
Oh.
There's loot in here.
How do I get that loot?
God, I don't need more money.
I can't buy anything.
Please.
I can't even buy anything.
So there's no point.
Okay.
Drop down.
no i'm not auto sorting i'm not i'm gonna use my brain i'm
not gonna become an ipad kid i can tetris i don't need a
computer to tetris for me okay let's see yeah we got ammo
how much ammo though that we have uh yeah i think we need
more rifle ammo Oh, here, let me combine these herbs
together.
Craft rifle ammo.
Okay, there you go.
This is a little better now.
Yeah, this is...
Oh, my gosh, this is good.
Alright.
Here we go.
I know!
AI has evolved so much!
Okay.
But I have the Doki way.
Whoa!
Adam Sandler?
Adam Sandler, think about your Netflix Dio's.
Oh my god.
Oh.
No, not more.
Bro, what?
Bro, what fucking protein do you have?
Can he die?
Oh, flee.
Okay, he cannot die.
We just run Guys, he can't die.
Don't worry Go go go go go
go go go go way Ashley
Bro This way this way this way Ashley, please!
Oh my god!
He can't die!
Bro, this is...
The power of the rich.
We did it.
That's fucking right.
Your god can't save you.
Tell your god to make you fly!
Ah, it's welcome.
Thank you for the one gift that should thank you.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, we did it.
The power of the Bible.
You just gotta believe.
Doki.
If we see him again, you run.
Oh, thank God.
There he is.
What about you?
I'll do my job.
God, please.
Where's the ammo?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, there we go.
There's the ammo.
Do you have anything new?
Okay, a key...
Oh, did I use up everything?
Wait, I think that key is, like, finished, right?
Yeah, I can sell this now.
And then...
This doesn't have any holes in it, so...
Yeah, it doesn't.
Alright, so we're good here.
And...
Oh, I can do, like, a combo...
Oh, wait, I can do a combo for this.
Alright, let's do a combo first.
Uh, 7,000.
Obviously, we'll do the chalice, because that one has the
best...
one all right wait oh wait i can do three right three three
three is the best three yeah three gemstones yes okay boop
boop boop nice my shiny chalice is complete now and then
this is the three different colors yay hey that was
beautiful time welcome all right sale time sell sell sell
sell sell oh my god guys don't talk to me anymore what is
thinking with the one guys talk to me when you have the
chalice
i'm in the next tax bracket
okay i did it i made it to the next tax bracket Let's go!
A well-tuned weapon can make up for a lack of skew, friend.
Damn, money really does change people.
Okay, let's see.
We gonna...
I don't think I need any of this.
She leveled that.
What am I gonna do with all this useless money?
I can't pay them to stop shooting me!
be careful be careful why what are oh wait is this the is
this the fucking thing where like he turns into a bat she's
sold out wait is this the bat level oh fuck this is the bat
level okay yeah i'm gonna i feel like i should buy the
rocket launcher to buy the rocket launcher for the fucking
Batman.
Oh, I missed out on this ammo.
Where the fuck?
Where's... Oh, there it is.
Oh, there's that money in.
Well, you told no, no, it's not.
Okay.
You know what?
I'll fucking...
I'll do... Okay, because he's not bat.
I'm gonna do... I have that money for this.
I'll just do the ammo capacity.
There we go.
Then I can have more ammo now.
I didn't put more ammo in there.
Alright.
Here we go.
It's bat time.
Alright.
It's batman time.
We don't need reload.
We're gamers.
Alright.
Here we go.
It's batman time.
Batman!
Oh!
By God.
He did learn to fly.
I told him to learn to fly and God gave me.
him the power what's your religion sir can i join it i mean
if i ask for flying powers and i instantly get it maybe it's
a good religion struggling abandon your body will are gone
you're shooting missionary you know that oh almighty grant
me the strength to crush your enemies son of a bitch Ashley,
run run Ashley, find the locker find a locker Ashley oh fuck
this is where I die sweets, thank you for the tent, get the
chips thank you, thank you oh oh oh you want to get ugly oh,
guy don't worry, I have the rifle okay Do headshots?
Oh, shit!
Oh, I'm sorry!
I have kitchen knife!
I'm...
Okay, those quick time events were way too quick.
Shink!
Control!
Okay, that's dumb.
Oh, God.
Oh, what?
Oh, my God.
Please get up.
Please.
Ah, spray.
It's the real quick time.
The really, really quick time event.
Oh, my God.
Stop.
Knife.
I need a reload.
Invade.
Super quick.
I
Okay, there we go Aim for the spine how the fuck was I guys
I can't tell what's ahead what's what's ahead and what's not
Okay, now I know why we up guys now I know why we fucking up
uh why we have to upgrade uh reload now i understand wait
does the seat does that not take damage like does this not
matter
oh fuck fire there we go okay okay okay he's gotta pick it
up again dodge out okay okay i didn't dodge guys It's okay.
It's okay.
I can tank another one.
I can tank another.
There we go.
I can tank one more hit.
You gotta pick up the barrel.
It's like Mario.
Oh, he doesn't pick up the barrel!
It's not like Mario!
Guys, I made a mistake.
It was not like Mario.
Guys, it was 100% not like Mario.
Yes, it was not like Mario, guys, I learned.
It was definitely not like Mario.
Oh shit, bro.
Oh shit, the actual quick dive!
Okay, here we go.
The weird Mario.
Okay, this is not a platform.
Oh, shit.
An eye.
Just like Mario.
Mario.
Oh, there we go.
I knew it.
Hoarding was always the right answer.
All right, here we go.
Thank you for the eye.
Give my regards to your God.
Is there any loot?
Okay, nice.
Oh, my God.
There was a lot of loot.
Give me a sec, Ashley!
I need the loot!
Guys, I might be inhaling a lot of smoke, Ashley, but this
is important.
This is very important to Leon.
Give me a sec.
Okay, let's see.
Look, I know I'm inhaling a lot of smoke right now, Ashley,
but you don't understand.
All right.
Where there's a ladder?
Oh, there is.
Okay, here you go.
Don't worry.
This fire is really fucking hot, but don't worry.
it's dangerous actually you don't understand my love for
loot transcends danger she will never understand okay oh
nice herb nice herb okay let's see you can combine that and
then we definitely need more wait do i okay we need more
shotgun ammo all right let's just reload that and then all
right i'm gonna definitely upgrade reload speed i realized
my mistake when i said i'm not upgrading reload speed i
realized that might have been a mistake did i just okay guys
we didn't see that wait i missed them no
actually no
No!
This fire's bound to catch their attention.
I'm not gonna turn into one of them, right?
No!
I don't know.
Maybe their god is, like, worth it.
Like, they get special powers.
I grabbed the eyeball, though.
I got the eyeball.
At least I have the cool eye.
I can't believe it.
That loot.
What do you mean always see that map?
There's literally nothing!
Oh, that loot.
It wasn't treasure, right?
If Ashley turns into a monster and Leon kills her, does she
drop loot?
Very good question.
okay there we are all right let's see wait there's a
treasure behind me actually there's a treasure behind us
where is it moors looking up there it is thank god i didn't
see i saw that thank god this time i looked at the map do
you think leon used conditioner or just champ dude look at
him yeah unless he's a fucking greasy ass dude i'm pretty
sure he uses no there's no way leon definitely is not like
he's not a neat so like i'm pretty sure he uses conditioner
he wants to continue the bloodline
well at least you don't have to worry about being followed
come on yeah his hair is way too shiny for no conditioner i
actually I don't use conditioner because like, um, I used to
swim a lot, uh, as a, as a kid.
And because of that, I fucked up my hair.
Uh, because I, like, as Asian parents do, they, they make
your kid do lots of swimming lessons.
They make your kid do a lot of different lessons.
So then I like did a lot of like swimming lessons and stuff.
Um, I never got past a single level because I couldn't do
the butterfly stroke or like the, the frog.
I call it the frog because they called it a frog.
And I like failed three classes.
um i failed the class three fucking times because i could
never do the frog i retook the class three fucking times and
it's not like the every time you take the class you do the
frog you have to learn all the things in that class the same
time like all we have to like always learn that same thing
over like all the other steps not just the froggy thing um
So, like, you know, I had to keep retaking it three fucking
times, and I could never get the frog right.
So I failed three fucking times.
And every time I had to learn the basics, front stroke,
backstroke, all that over and over again.
But it's always the frog.
I could never do the frog.
Anyway, the moral of that story, I don't use conditioner
because, like, my hair, like, gets, like, natural, like,
it's, like, gets, like, greasy, really really quick so like
i always have to take like uh because of like the swimming
ruined my hair so like i couldn't do conditioner anymore
because like my scalp is like super fucked up because
so so like i used to use conditioner but like i had to stop
because like my hair got super fucked up that I could never,
I can't use conditioner anymore.
Let's see.
That's the moral of the story.
Alright.
Next.
Trauma dump.
Sorry for trauma dumping, by the way.
May Thank you for the search.
Thank you.
With all that chlorine, you got your hair bleached for free.
Where do we go?
Let's see.
Come to the courtyard inside of the castle.
We can meet up there.
Ciao.
How does he have my phone number?
Who gave him my phone number?
Did I give him my phone?
That's slipping my number.
Did I slip?
Did I slip in my number before he left?
I was like, he, he, ha ha, here's my number, he, wink.
Oh,
yeah, all those crows, you know what's money.
You know you owe me money, crows.
Okay, let's grab some fucking barrels, though.
Nice.
Oh, hey.
What's this?
The vintage compass.
good that's money where the fuck is my merchant is he in
here merchant what do you have i've got something new what
is this increase the drop rate of red herbs i don't need
that exclusive
exclusive upgrade regardless wait what does this mean oh
treasure map you need that
anymore never mind I can't even afford that okay I can't
afford anything I'm poor all right let's see black tail is
my gun the strongest right now wait is this oh that's a wait
the semi-automatic rifle the broken butterfly resources wait
I can bomb resources now rocket launcher Magnum ammo Wait,
are any of these, are any of these pistols better than my
original pistol?
Get the stingray?
Why?
Stingray, three times power against weak points, penetrated.
Wait, is that a rifle?
Is that like a sniper?
Oh, a sniper would better fire it.
Broken butterfly best magnum?
Ooh.
Do I buy the magnum?
Is that better than my pistol?
you didn't get i think you get magnum for free from a puzzle
okay i'm gonna buy the rifle time is money mate this is uh
it's on sale it's for bosses the butterfly which one's for
boss guys which was for bosses oh magnum is a boss killer oh
that's good i love boss killers Guns not just about
shooting, it's about reloading.
You'll know what I'm talking about.
Go on, take this as well.
Oh, nice.
I love free stuff.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, does that mean I can throw this away?
Can I throw the SR?
A bolt action.
Wait, can I sell this now?
Guys, can I sell this now?
The SR?
No?
My rifle is better?
Wait, guys, which rifle is better?
Which is better?
The SR or the...
SR is the better rifle for power?
Okay, I'm going to go for SR for the power.
And then I'll upgrade this.
Stinger is better.
Guys.
Guys, you all have different opinions.
You all have different opinions.
Okay, I'll...
Trust.
Okay, I'm gonna trust the guy that says trust.
Okay, and I'll upgrade my...
I'll upgrade my Magnum.
Boom.
Okay.
And then I'm gonna upgrade the reload speed of my fucking
shotgun.
Because I realize Okay, now guys now you can talk to me
again.
I I'm broke again.
I'm broke guys I'm broke I'm broke now
All right, let's see do I have enough crafter?
Wait, I could have upgraded no I already used all my fucking
money on suit.
Oh my god, where's the suitcase?
No, you guys are lying.
There's no suit case upgrade what do you mean there's no
fucking okay okay i almost got tricked all right i was got
lied to i was like no all right it's okay wait what is this
oh adam sandler courtyard's got to be through that gate Oh
no, it's a little boy.
The evil boy.
I don't think our hosts are going to roll up.
The tiny evil boy.
I can snipe all these people.
What is that?
I'm guessing it's not for decoration.
The dragon, thank you, thank you, thank you.
What you got is for power.
Singering is for DPS, which is which one you like more is I
like power.
Can I just snipe you now?
No, he's way too far.
I can't do 300 meters.
Okay, let's see.
We gotta go here.
Where are you scared of?
Keep your voice down.
Oh, whoops.
Sorry.
I forgot to keep my voice down.
Okay, we go this way.
Let's see.
Yeah, we have to go this way.
Whoa, what's that?
Bro, when was the last time there was castle maintenance,
guys?
Wait, I don't like that.
Are people dying?
Whoa!
Okay, boot knife.
See, that's better than kitchen knife.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, what the fuck was that?
Oh, that's not good.
Now they're fucking upgraded.
now oh no that is not good that is not good don't let him
get too close well that's great i have fucking ashley with
me i would love to not get too close when this is here
nice got shotgun shells okay all right we're gonna that's
the boss killer right okay we're gonna put that shortcut no
this shortcut killer so like it should be over here and then
we'll put this here there you go this is not good there was
they were not one hit did you not see how many fucking
bullets it took that was not one hit what do you mean that
was 100 not one hit okay sorry i had to make there's no door
oh they can one hit me oh that's different that changes
everything wait that actually changes everything
all right let us let us craft some more shotgun i don't have
enough shotgun okay never mind let's not craft
hello hello oh i don't know like that they're chanting
something wait how did they see me what is that bow oh that
is okay i don't think they can hit that
guys i don't think oh wait don't worry i can use this as
cover
where are they Where are they?
Come on, pick me.
Come on.
What the fuck?
That's bullshit.
I see you.
What are you doing?
Ashley, please stay behind me.
This is bullshit.
The way they're hiding, I hate that.
this look at them look at the way they're hiding look at
these cowards there we go like you're gonna get shot you
might as well just peek me there we go like you're gonna get
shot regardless all right here we got the fucking gunpowder
like Just fucking peek me!
They're very stealthy.
Woo!
Okay, that's not cool.
That is not cool.
I like how it...
I get the cutscene after.
Yes, they do.
Where is it coming from?
I don't know where the catapult is Like, oh, it's over there
Okay, Ashley, please Please do not get catapulted That is my
only dream, Ashley There we go I don't know how I saw it,
but there it was
Oh shit, wait, there's more than one Wait, where's the other
catapult?
I guess this is their idea of a warm welcome.
Where the fuck is the other catapult?
Okay, I gotta make sure...
What?
What did you come from?
Shit.
Nigs.
I've got your butt.
Nice.
Where the fuck did they come from?
Ashley, are you all right?
Yeah, thanks.
Oh, Jesus.
There's the next catapult.
I don't know where the next catapult is, and that's the
scary part.
No, no, no, no!
Who should...
Hey, look, there's a gem.
Oh, my God, it's over there.
There's no barrel!
How am I supposed to get it when there's no barrel?
Oh, God.
There's no barrel.
I don't know where it is.
Oh, what the?
What?
There you go.
Don't stab.
Please don't turn.
You can one shot apparently.
Okay, I'm going to see if I can see the barrel from here.
i'm not what do you mean i am not okay oh god oh god oh god
it's blocking every it's blocking everything where do i go
i'm so lost i'm so lost
oh my god oh my god where do we go there's so many areas oh
there it is good it is actually Ashley, there it is.
Downstairs!
Okay.
Okay, I don't know where to go.
I'm just going to stay back here.
This is the beginning.
This is the...
I went the wrong way, Ashley.
We got...
I went the wrong way.
I went backwards.
Ashley, I'm sorry.
I'm so lost.
Ashley, I don't know where his left and right.
Ashley.
Wait, I could craft, though.
What do I need, though?
Do I need a rifle?
Actually, give me a sec.
Uncle Leon is trying to figure out ammo management.
Uncle Leon needs to work on his ammo situation.
Is it here?
No!
It's locked!
To get creative.
Oh my god, actually.
There's a barrel without loot!
Nice.
Okay.
I need to figure this out again.
Uncle Leon doesn't know what to do.
Uncle Leon is so fucked up right now.
Oh.
Oh, there, there, there, there.
Here we go.
I figured it out, guys.
I'm not that stupid.
This could work.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I can shoot the cannon!
oh my god this could definitely work I like that okay I'm
gonna bring out the shotgun just in case I get like shocked
again please why are there no lockers in this castle
where are my lockers in this castle how do I get out of here
uncle Leon is lost again
was there an exit here that i didn't oh there was a ladder
it's painted yellow i should have known i should have known
the yellow paint strat i always forget about the paint strat
the barrels though why is there so wait i could have shot
this they were they were there this entire time looking at
me wait where's where's ashley oh what how how you how did
you get injured okay this is awkward all right let's just
hope no fucking catapult kills her like this is like all i'm
betting on wait a minute where did you come
I'm going all in with the catapult not fucking me up
Wait what the fuck Oh shit
Oh she's okay that's good That's all that matters She's okay
She's okay guys There we go Alright we're okay We're okay
Holy fuck How Oh my god Bro Oh my god Okay guys it had to be
done Okay here we go Alright we need A couple We need like
two more blues Where's another blue?
I swear to god There were more blues somewhere where?
I swear I saw a lot of them.
The gate?
Oh, is that the gate?
Oh, there was it.
Liars?
There's no blues here.
Oh, there's a blue here, though.
There we go.
We need two more.
Oh, yeah.
No, no, it doesn't have it.
This map, we didn't pick up the...
quick pick up the quest yet for this.
We'll hit the gate with the cannon later.
We gotta do the side quest.
This side quest is more important.
Guys, no no no.
We have to.
There's two more that we need to do.
This side quest is the most important thing right now.
Is there anything in here?
Maybe I'll look down here.
I'm going to double check if there's...
Oh, there it is.
There's one here.
Nice.
Neither is one here.
Okay, we're missing one more.
We're missing one last blue.
There's one below on a tree.
There's so many trees.
We're literally in a forest.
This castle is in the forest.
Which tree?
Oh, I didn't see this.
I was so fucking...
panicking i didn't see all these boxes nice all right oh
wait i didn't see this too oh my god the elegant bangle oh
my god there's so much loot the greener tree it's over there
doki that tree right there doki is right there doki that
tree god it's over here the greener tree you know that one
yeah that tree over there trees by the merchant oh it's by
them you know what you could have said that you could have
just said tree by the merchant boom
oh i see the request that went well oh warning next time the
request is right there
okay wait my bad is the other tree sorry my bad i meant that
tree yeah tree there's no trees in the castle guys oh boom
boom all right here we go now we have the request it's right
here where's there okay actually this is this important.
Uncle Leon needs to get the medallions.
Because Uncle Leon needs fucking upgrades.
You don't let Uncle Leon do this.
You don't love him.
How do you get downstairs again?
Oh, this way.
Okay.
We need to grab that tree.
That's apparently over here.
Thank God Leon doesn't have stamina.
Fars.
Thank fucking God.
Where is it?
Where is this tree?
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
It's that tree right here.
There we go.
It was that tree all along.
Okay, reload.
I gotta make more shock enamel later.
Nice.
Reload.
All right, we're good to go.
All right, Ashley, we're going in.
Yeah.
Open sesame.
You have stuff?
Seller.
I did it.
Okay.
You have the box upgrade?
No, you doesn't.
Okay, I need a...
What the fuck?
Oh, yeah.
I can sell that.
I can sell this.
Okay.
Do I have two circles?
No, I don't.
I don't have two circles yet, so I'll just sell these for
now.
Sell time.
Save.
Nice.
Alright, actually, here we go.
We're about to be at the part where I have to play, yes,
you, and that's going to be the worst part.
Hello?
Adam Sandler?
A most warm welcome to my castle.
Such a pleasure to find out.
Here he is, little boy.
Mr. Kennedy.
Who the hell are you?
Me?
Oh, please, call me Ramon.
And allow me to get straight to the point.
I would like you to hand the girl there over to me now.
Yeah, if that chance, Ramon.
He has a Benjamin Button disease.
With me.
There's no, he's 20.
Holy shit, what happened?
This man was stressed way too hard.
The girl must be ours.
With a girl as the very source, your United States, and then
the entire world shall overflow with his grace.
For that is the iron wheel of my master, the most holy Lord
Sadler.
so then you will comply yes never you are the lady i was
just love her her outfit now that he has chosen dead
look netflix was just not as lucrative okay the netflix deal
ran out oh my god excuse me That's a lot.
Oh god, stay close to me.
Stay close to me.
Stay close!
Wait!
No!
Okay.
Reload time.
I swear to God, do not get hit!
Ashley!
That is my only demand!
Oh, I missed every shot!
that was okay that was a little awkward there that i sort of
missed every shot that's a little awkward
all right it's okay it's okay everything is fine we survived
we're survivors uh there's like so much loot upstairs god
damn it's in the chest it's okay i'll just Smash some jars.
It's not my home.
Not my home.
Smashy.
Smashy smash.
Is this.
God, I don't have anything.
Why is it so foggy?
Did someone put, like, some fog machine in here?
Wait, Merchant, you just watched this happen?
No, shit.
There was a fucking battle, like, fucking two meters away
from you, sir.
Bro.
The most evil guy, Robin.
salad pie.
Yoshi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
There's like nothing I need to do here.
I'm just gonna save.
Alright, here we go.
Merch just... Yeah, the merchant.
If it's not gold, it doesn't matter.
Can I open this door?
How would I be able to go in?
Oh, I have to drop down from there.
Okay.
There's so much loot, but I could not get any of it.
Gap in the wall.
Oh, Ashley, go in.
This is your only job.
I don't ask for much, Ashley.
Ashley, I ask for almost nothing.
Please.
This is the only time I ask for anything.
It's open.
There you go.
nice thank god you're useful thank fucking god
actually i don't ask for much oh okay i thought i had to
like make her go through this too look for another way oh is
this oh okay i was not actually go back actually go back
actually go back i didn't i didn't realize this was where i
was supposed to go i have to still The looting is so
important here.
Okay.
There is a chest.
Oh, elegant perfume bottle.
Something I can sell.
Okay.
Let's see.
That is the door where I can't open.
Knock, knock.
I'm alive.
Okay.
We're going to save again because, um, because, like, you
know, every time you make a little bit of progress you gotta
save so you don't want it this is efficiency because what
happens if i fucking just die because i don't want to do
this again every time you make a little bit of progress you
have to save so you don't have to that's why i have 51 saves
this is exactly why we have 51 saves guys it's just see
because what if i just die spread out with me with me okay i
just okay nice okay it's made of wood so i can i like how
it's just that is there nothing else
here's something oh it's above me okay i knew it that's like
i hear it Okay, let's see.
I knew I heard something.
Uh, wait, what's that treasure?
Is it not?
It must be above.
Must be above, because I can't get it.
Looks like we can continue on this way.
Oh my god.
God damn it, it's dark.
I hate it.
I hate this.
I fucking hate this.
Okay, he's definitely dead.
Oh no, this is a torture room.
Is there any yet?
Oh my gosh, no.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Can you move?
Poor bastard.
That's no way to go.
Can I not just like untie him and like fucking move?
I was awoken in the middle of the night once again.
It's those awful noises coming from the basement.
The sounds of nails clawing at the stone walls.
and the writhing moan of curses that man harbors enough hate
to ruin this world he once served the lord of the castle as
the torturer like his father and grandfather before him it's
one of the most unsightly legacies left by the salazar
family even among his family he was special he enjoyed his
work wholeheartedly and had a talent for it he was gifted at
tormenting others His ability soon attracted the master's
interest, and when he took him to the dungeon, No, I can't
write anymore.
I won't.
I don't want to recall what happened down there.
My mind can't take it.
It will break me.
I was ordered to attend him, to feed him, dispose of the
fifth, all while listening to that wretched voice every
night.
I can't take it anymore.
I've had enough.
not tolerate one more night in this castle.
I shall leave tomorrow.
Go far away where that voice cannot reach my ears.
Damn.
Bro, your voice was shit.
Definitely won't be doing any ASMR.
None shall escape.
Okay, Salazar, like that little guy, I assume the little guy
is Salazar.
And like his voice reminds me of an actor.
Like, I swear, like, it looks just like him, too.
Like, the act, like, some old-timey actor from a long time
ago.
Oh, hey, the Iron Maiden.
I'm trying to, like, remember who.
Like, his, his, the whole voice, too.
What was that?
I was having a Zatudan.
Like, there was an actor, like, that sounds and looks just
like him.
I can't remember who.
Oh.
Don't worry, I have my shotgun.
Don't worry, don't worry, Ashley.
I have my shotgun, Ashley.
Don't worry.
Something's gonna come in here.
The time, the light is lost.
I fucking knew it!
It's okay, I have the shotgun!
Oh, where would the shotgun go?
Which pattern is meta?
Can I just kill him?
Okay, guys, can I just kill him?
Okay.
Is this...
Yeah?
Try!
Why?
Oh!
Tell me to shoot him!
Why didn't you tell me to shoot him?
Okay.
Okay, I have a grenade.
Boom!
Oh, God.
I'm right out of ammo.
Oh, why
did I shoot him?
Oh, God.
Oh, my God, bro.
Invade.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot he's blind.
He's blind.
Don't walk into anything.
No.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
He's blind.
Okay.
That's okay, we did it.
There goes my healing items.
There it goes.
I don't need a heal item.
There goes all my heals.
There it goes.
go oh hey but i got three shotgun ammo out of that yeah
yippee okay
okay that was a little stupid of me to just shoot him that
was That was a little stupid of me.
Not gonna lie.
And then I kept running into the spikes.
Because I got scared.
Because I was panicking.
I got a little scared, guys.
I can't think when I'm scared.
I can't.
I hate.
I don't think when I start panicking all I can think of is
like shoot shoot the gun shoot the gun don't keep just shoot
the gun worry about stuff later just shoot okay open the
door
lots of things happened
fear makes you do crazy things i need to go save now i need
to grab those heal sprays i stocked up on where are my
chickens i missed the chickens if only i have the chickens
remember when i had all those eggs i remember
That was the good life Right there What can I interest you
here?
Is that bingo for circles?
It is.
I need like two reds I miss the chickens I miss the free
eggs I miss the free eggs man Those were luxurious I didn't
know it was a luxury I I didn't know they were a luxury.
Can I use this?
No, that's the dungeon key.
Can I use the dungeon key for anything?
I don't think so.
No eggs for me.
Why can't the fucking castle people raise chickens?
Where are my chickens?
Alright.
Use.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Gunpowder.
Oh, that is good.
We actually need more of that.
We do not have any shotgun ammo.
Please, Ashley.
Help is not a concern right now.
Ooh, I hear a little little toy.
Where is he?
There you are.
I see you.
I already missed, apparently, a few anyway, so that doesn't
matter.
Oh, nice.
Spinelle.
Herbs.
I need the yellow herb.
That's the only thing I'm missing right now.
Okay, did I get everything?
The treasury.
Oh, no.
I'm having some fucking...
Fucking PTSD right now.
He's seeing the treasury.
Oh, no.
Wow.
I'm confused.
Oh, no.
I see this and I'm confused now.
Okay, there is lore.
Okay, the iron sword.
We got the sword.
What if I...
We got the gold sword.
Okay.
And then we got the rusted sword.
Oh!
It's a puzzle!
Can we not open this?
What do we do?
What does this do?
Okay.
Alright.
So obviously, this one would be the rusted sword because
he's killing people?
No.
No, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Okay.
Let's see.
This one will obviously be the gold sword.
Because he's gone.
And then... Oh no, I'm right!
Wait, I can ring those gongs.
What?
But, like, what about this room?
This one has to be the iron sword.
And then...
Why is there one sword empty?
Why is this sword empty, though?
I don't have all the swords.
Oh, I don't have all the swords!
Oh, I was gonna say, like, where the fuck are the other
swords?
Like, where are the other swords?
yeah
and then
what did i waste my ammo
oh wait okay it's dear bird snake okay dear bird snake okay
it's a puzzle wait but which do i know goes first dear bird
snake Okay, here we go.
Oh, it's timed?
Oh!
Okay.
Order is not necessary?
Oh.
Wait, what?
Well, clearly it was not timed.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Now I don't think...
it's timed anymore no i don't think it's timed okay hey this
definitely did not feel timed anymore
hey then what's this
why can i ring that but not the others this doesn't it look
like it's telling some kind of story yes i know actually i
know Okay, whoops, sorry, that's not what I wanted.
Okay, bloody sword.
There we go.
And then iron sword, rusted sword.
Bam.
Door open.
I guess you're right.
All right, nice.
Of course I'm right.
Ashley, I didn't need your help.
That's what chat is for.
Ashley, are you chat?
No.
You didn't join my membership.
You're not subscribed.
When you subscribe to me, Ashley, then you can backseat me.
There's a fucking snake!
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Why can't I just step on it?
That snake.
Okay.
Actually, you can only backseat me when you subscribe.
Keonic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
A fake fan.
I know, right?
Fucking fake fan.
Fake ass.
Oh, nice.
Gold bangle.
We need that.
All right.
Oh, we go.
Let's see.
Oh, I don't like this.
Hang on.
This is the same room as before, isn't it?
You're so smart.
Actually, you're so smart.
Head for the courtyard.
Where the fuck?
Oh, that's the courtyard.
Okay, but there's loot.
Actually.
There's loot, though.
We can't just head to the courtyard.
We need to grab the loot.
Okay.
there is oh wait can we lower the ladder oh that's so
convenient thank fucking guy wait can i jump here i don't
know if this is like for jumping
oh okay ring ring wait is that snake okay that's a snake
okay where the fuck is the snake Thank you for the 10 gifted
ships.
Thank you.
Can I jump?
Oh, I can.
Thank fucking god It's called You wouldn't understand You're
not as cool as me Is that snake?
No, that's bird.
What the fuck is snake?
Oh, wait, I'll be back I'll be back actually there's loot
here Nice Okay guys.
Oh, I thought I was gonna kick it Sashkin, welcome to the
tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Chai, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, we need to set...
Wait, where did you come from?
Okay, do we not meet the dungeon key anymore?
No, we don't.
Okay.
Whoa, sorry, I'm like fucking freaking out right now.
Goat, Bangal, and iron glass.
And...
Can we...
If the poison glands are removed, it may be okay yeah never
mind i'm not gonna eat the snake i'm just gonna sell it yeah
i'm gonna sell it i don't trust myself i don't trust myself
i feel like something bad is gonna happen if i try to eat
the snake all right let's see we gotta where the fuck is the
ladder oh there it is We need to find the snake.
Joneses, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Donate and doki and Leon save the gun.
But it's fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let me be here.
Is snake here?
Is this snake?
No, this is bird.
Wait, I was here.
I literally jumped from here.
I couldn't count.
It's this way.
Sorry, Ashley.
this way!
Whoop!
Here I go.
Whoa!
Snake here?
Snake?
Where the fuck?
Where's the snake?
Where the fuck's the snake?
Bro.
Oh, in front of me.
Sorry, guys.
I'm blind.
Whoa!
Say!
What the fuck?!
Bro, I almost shot her.
I actually almost shot her.
Bro, she scared the shit out of me.
Okay, here we go.
Holy shit, Ashley.
Don't do that.
That actually was an Ashley jump scare.
Don't fucking do that again.
Holy fuck.
That scared the shit out of me, man.
Don't fucking do that again.
Don't do that again.
Okay, shock...
Oh my god, 17 for Magnum?
We're now... We're using the Magnum until we fucking go to
the boss.
The Scene Kid jumpscare.
Scene Kid!
You're never prepared for the Scene Kid.
Okay, gunpowder.
Nice.
Oh.
What is this?
What is this Salazar?
Hello.
No, no I'm not.
No, I'm not.
I'm taking delivery preparing some entertainment for you.
What do you mean by that?
The Gallen Knights protects the princess bear.
What is this?
I don't like this.
I don't...
Salazar I don't like this I don't shoot the bell where's the
bell there's no bells here where do you see the fucking bell
am I blind again am I am I blind again guys where where's
the bell
Where the fuck's the bell?
I am using eyes.
I don't see no bell.
Use your third eyes.
Oh, the speakerphone.
Bro, where the fuck's the speakerphone?
Where did the speakerphone come from?
Like...
Oh, this is not good.
I'm gonna grab...
some ammo and some money okay this way is quest time this
way is items this way is loot
typewriter typewriter nice there are some parasites that
have the ability to control their host this is basic
knowledge among most biologists but not much is known as to
how the bear it the following is a list of several such
parasites the dichro once the larvae of the parasite
migrates to the ant they altered oh this is the last of us
that's the the mushrooms the larva this parasite makes their
home inside the brain of a fish such as the yellow tail and
uh parrot bass once infected the fish makes its way up to
the water surface where it will swim until eaten by seabirds
oh yeah so the reason why is that the birds when they eat it
the parasite like um the parasite can only like reproduce in
their shit so like the fish you know the way it spreads is
by bird poop i know this i don't know i don't remember when
i learned it but i know it this parasites develop in the
snail's eye stalks oh i've seen these they're they make it
look like they're at a rave those parasites make the snails
look like they're at a rave um this is also a lot of them
are like a lot of them spread by bird poop uh they alter the
snail's behavior and force it to move to the top of the
plant to make it more visible to birds once eaten by the
bird the parasite will complete its metamorphosis into an
adult the rainbow snails yeah they're in fucking pain and
they are dying but it looks cool okay no okay this is the
objective so i'm gonna go this way Alright, yes, we don't go
that way.
I love it when we don't go that way.
Wait, does that make an open this door?
Yeah, right?
I can!
Nice.
Shortcut.
Yay!
I'll never go back that way.
Oh, can I just shoot it?
Oh, it's next to the door?
Wait, so I just shoot this?
Where?
Where's the speaker?
Or you mean the downstairs door?
Where's the door?
Guys, where's the bell?
Oh by the typewriter!
Other door!
Where's the bell?
Bell?
Oh barrel though.
Well, guys, I swear to fucking God, are you fucking with me?
I swear to...
Outside this...
Oh, outside this...
Guys, I swear to fucking God, are you fucking with me?
Oh, there it is!
This one, right?
Like that?
It's too late now.
No!
Don't pause.
What happens if I do it?
Okay, I'm just gonna save.
Look, guys.
That's not a bell.
This is not a bell.
It's like, it's like, it's a speaker.
Guys, it's because you didn't say speaker.
If you said speaker, I would have known what you're talking
about.
But you said bell.
What the fuck is a bell?
That's not a bell.
Those do not look like that.
I just realized I had to do the fucking maze.
I just remembered the maze.
The maze fucking sucked, man.
Fudge top.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, since you're a bird too, can you make sure you get
yourself checked after this?
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, no.
God damn it.
I've got my rifle.
I got my rifle.
God fucking damn it.
Here we go.
Actually, God fucking damn it.
Damn it, I hate this level.
I remember this.
Where?
Wait, what?
Who fucking shot you?
Oh my god, I hate this.
Oh god.
Oh, guys.
Get over here!
This one sucks more.
As a...
This one sucks more in the OG.
What?
Who fucking shot you?
Where?
I don't see the arrows.
Oh, my God, there.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
This is way worse.
I like the old one.
I got her.
Where did you go, Ashley?
Where did you go?
Yeah.
I am not okay.
I don't know why I said I'm okay.
I'm not okay.
I do not feel okay right now.
I do not feel okay.
Really?
I like the old one more can I, because I could literally
just stand still.
Unless that's a different level I was thinking of.
I know there was one where I can just snipe and stand still.
Oh, God.
Where is it?
I hear them.
I hear they're just breathing heavily.
Where are you?
He's just breathing heavily Below Okay guys I need loot guys
I need loot first I don't have a lot Please tell me I can
crash shock and so Thank God oh thank God Okay
Okay I need to make sure
Wait what?
Wait what was that sound?
What does that sound?
What is that sound?
Where are they?
What is that?
I don't like that sound.
I don't like that sound!
Where are they?
Where the fuck are they?
Stop whispering!
Stop whispering, please.
Stop whispering.
I don't like it when you whisper.
I'm gonna get rid of these guys.
I just want to get rid of these guys first like I okay is he
okay I don't know if I'm shooting him is he getting shot at
I can't tell
are you getting shot at bro I'm just gonna use my pistol
like that was I can't believe I wasted my rifle ammo I can't
believe it bro I can't tell if he's getting a shot at.
Like, he can't.
All right.
Is he taking damage?
He is, right?
No, it's a waste.
My pistol can kill him.
It's a fucking waste.
It's a waste of a good flashbang.
Jesus, he's so tanky.
He's so...
walking i can't see them
he's still walking oh he has a helmet that's cheating one
grenade versus a hundred bullets look that's the risk i'm
willing to take i was the risk i'm willing to take look i
need that flash grenade you don't understand oh there's a up
here sorry give me a sec there's there's two bases up here
that i missed oh i don't like this i don't like this why is
it intensifying
oh what's that sound
oh god i'm scared i know there's one more like he's here
somewhere He's here somewhere, guys.
There's one more.
Bro, I don't even have flash grenades.
What the fuck?
What are you guys talking about?
We don't even have...
I'm like, we don't even have flash grenades.
Why were you yelling me?
We don't even have one.
I can't believe you guys yelled at me about the flash
grenades.
And we never even had one
I can't believe it There see I told you eventually we will
kill these guys
We had enough bullets.
Oh my god, I could have shot this
Yeah, he doesn't know
There we go Nice oh not nice not nice not nice not not nice
we're gonna use the shotgun because apparently he's one he
can one-shot you there you go wait you're still alive okay
it's pistol time because i don't know if you have a head
that's the thing sometimes i don't know oh
god okay i can't
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
I think that's all of them.
We're good.
And he just gives me money.
Nice.
The mouth is the spot.
Oh, okay.
I couldn't tell.
It's so hard to see if he has a mouth.
Like, where's your head?
I couldn't tell where the head was.
It's too confusing.
Like, he was just all mouth.
No head.
okay i need the thing it's a worm you can't kill a worm you
can chop it but you can't kill it okay got the wheel this
should do the trick okay wheel time
yeah we're why don't i have salt if only i had the salt who
just That is exactly what I've been missing.
Oh!
There!
Please stop!
Oh, God.
I don't have...
Okay, it's time.
It's time.
I know I have the quick thing, but I'm too scared.
Oh shit!
Fuck you!
I'm gonna use this for it.
Ashley, come over here!
Ashley, Ashley, Ashley, Ashley!
Ashley, Ashley!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We gotta...
Okay.
Oh!
He jumped in the eye!
He jumped in this guy!
Ashley, Ashley, Ashley!
We gotta lead him to an explosive!
I said this is our only hope now!
I don't have a lot of ammo anymore!
I'm fucked up!
Please tell me he's dead.
He's not dead!
Ashley, Ashley, Ashley!
Okay, here we go.
We're fine, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
We're really poor right now.
But we're fine.
Please live.
Oh my god, we're okay.
We're very poor right now.
Our economy is in shambles.
But we are okay.
I'm not even gonna bother using my fucking sniper.
Oh my god.
Bro, really?
Bro, I'm just...
Bro, I do not need, like, sniper ammo to kill you.
I can see your head.
Oh my god!
Bro, he- Actually, please.
Please.
Please!
Catch it!
Oh, God.
Holy shit.
Okay.
We're fine.
It's fine.
We'll use the pistol.
We literally do not need rifles for this.
Like, our aim is good enough.
You okay?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Please.
tell me I have enough to craft.
Okay, we need shotgun ammo.
We're so poor.
I need yellow herbs.
Oh my god, okay, we're fine.
I think we're good.
I think we're good now.
I think I think we're okay.
Alright, time to use the wheel.
Time to use the wheel.
Oh my god, we have nothing left.
Yes, Ashley, so awesome.
So awesome.
Guys, remember when I had 70 bullets?
I remember.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god, don't tell me there's more.
Don't tell me there is more.
Don't tell me there's more.
Bro!
The economy hit hard.
This part fucking sucks.
I miss sniping.
We go back.
If we trigger somebody we go back.
Oh, no.
Bro.
God, there's only resources.
What about these sniper ammo?
All right.
All right, here you go.
Little over the top, don't you think?
like Mario.
It's just like Mario.
Oh my god, I don't have enough ammo.
Please.
I don't know if I can protect you.
No, this is it.
This is the sniper area.
Okay, Ashley, here we go.
You're gonna be okay?
This is it.
Okay.
Don't have a lot.
But okay.
Oh shit, okay.
Alright.
Oh my god, please Leon.
You're not supposed to be missing right now.
Oh my god.
What do you want?
What do you mean?
Guys!
Chill!
Actually, chill!
Oh, thank you.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
I have to...
Please!
Let me alone!
Oh my god!
Get down!
Get down, Ashley!
Okay, I'm fucking...
Jesus Chris, I'm gonna knife now.
Thank god.
I just had enough ammo.
I actually just got enough ammo.
Thank fucking god.
Like, give me, I'm so fucking full.
now.
Got a drop down.
Oh my God.
Okay, craft rifle ammo.
Because by God, we need this shit.
Okay.
Don't say that.
Don't fucking say that.
I'm back in the lower tax bracket.
Okay.
What am I going to do?
$95,000!
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
Nice.
We made it.
Right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, Ashley.
Get close.
Alright.
Thank you.
Oh, thank God there's boxes.
Your guns demand funds.
Why can't I just buy ammo?
This is exactly why we're not doing the harder difficulty.
I would have been soft locked.
100%.
I would have been fucking soft locked.
Okay, let's see.
Wait, what?
Open up.
What do you mean?
What the fuck do you mean?
There's a gap in the wall.
Ashley got open up for me Ashley Robert thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you all right here we go I found
more shotgun ammo nice actually cough later open door please
please you sure you're good okay we're okay Everything is
fine.
Ashley, look, I'm not coughing, Ashley.
Come on.
Looks like the right place.
What's going on?
Are you feeling the scene?
What's the inner scene kid saying?
Instead of worrying about her, worry about your own skin.
Bullish little lamb.
What?
Oh, they're controlling me.
Or he's controlling her.
10 points child Ashley please please no more of your scene
roleplay
Ashley give me my knife that costs like $30,000 Ashley
Ashley my knife is more expensive than you
Ashley please she's got Eva No!
You're supposed to be seen!
Not emo!
It's not just a face.
Wait, where are we at?
Okay, we're starting chapter 8 now.
Oh, and we never seen our, like, chapter results.
Not!
Look at that!
That's almost 90%.
Ruse, come in.
Things went to shit.
We took refuge inside a castle.
These wounds, they will not hear.
Roost.
Hello.
I lost her, and she lost my knife.
Damn it.
So much for that.
My knife.
Wait, this is...
Oh, I got my knife back.
Okay, that's good.
That's alright.
I don't give a fuck.
I got my knife.
It's alright, guys.
My knife is still with me.
It took me so long to find her.
And now I have to try and find her again.
Wait, what's over here?
Huh?
I feel like there would be something here.
Because there's a fountain in the courtyard.
The fish!
I'm gonna eat the fish.
Eat the rich.
That's why there's a fountain.
I knew it.
I knew there's a fountain here for a reason.
Nice.
Now I have food.
Okay, now I have fish.
Okay, this is a mess.
Give me a second.
This is a mess.
Okay.
Let us sort this out real fast.
No, all my kitchen knives.
They're gone.
God, I have so many resources, but no fucking gunpowder.
This is sad.
Okay, nice.
All right.
A little snack for me.
I really need it because I wasted so much money.
I wasted all my heels.
Oh yeah, super rough, man.
Do you have anything new?
Matilda.
Scope.
None of these are good.
Wait, is there the box upgrade?
Body armor!
Oh, my wares are in tiptoe.
Oh, this is good!
Nice.
Okay, we needed that, actually.
Let's see.
Stingray.
Okay, we don't need any of this.
All right, we have...
Oh, yeah, we should get the yellow herb.
We might as well.
I feel like we should.
Okay, let's see.
Do I have enough gems?
No.
I don't...
Okay, I can sell this.
I still don't have a submachine gun.
so I can sell that.
And then...
Anything else?
It should be good.
Oh!
We're inflation's hitting hard, man.
Alright, we're good.
We're good to go.
Wait, can I upgrade my body armor?
Can I?
No, I can repair it.
Alright, let's see.
Reload speed.
Rate of fire.
uh ammo capacity i feel like all those weapons to finish
that's all we need apply ammo capacity for my pistol i might
as well
we don't need the rifle fire ray we're so healthy Hit my
shots!
We're so...
We're okay.
We'll be fine.
Okay, fine, fine.
I'll do a reload speed.
We're a bug on the back wall?
What?
What about the bug?
What about the bug on the back wall?
What about it?
What?
What do you mean?
There's nothing here.
Oh, on the fountain!
There's a...
There's a bug?
Whoa, what the fuck?
What was that?
What the fuck was that?
What the fuck?
Do you guys see that?
The left side.
Oh, hey!
Oh, there's a beetle!
There he is!
you meant like game bug i thought that's what you meant
because my graphic started glitching i was like whoa you're
right i was like whoa guys you're right there is a bug
okay here you go um time to sell is this for selling right
yeah i'm pretty sure it's for selling that was the fence
yeah i thought i thought like the game was broken wait now
eat it oh well too late i sold it i care about money more
whoops i ate i i sold it Sorry, money was more important,
guys.
Alright, here we go.
Whew.
Oh, no.
Wait, what?
Are these guys dead already?
Oh, they are.
Bro, what the fuck?
Are they all dead?
Oh, yeah, they are definitely all dead.
Yeah.
Yeah, go.
Oh, it's this way.
Oh, I remember this.
Okay, I'm gonna try and...
I just sniped in.
Wait, do I go from here?
I'm so confused.
I don't see them down there.
See?
I don't think I should.
Are you scared?
Yes.
When you meet Am I... Yes, I am!
What do you... How is that a question?
Alright, for one Akasupa, I'll vault over.
That's right.
Yes, I'm testing you all.
that's right put the money where your mouth is that's okay
right the bribe that's right then that is why i'm not
vaulting over oh okay i'm doing it okay bacon thank you for
the akasupa thank you thank you all right here we go oh it
was fine there was nothing to worry about all right the The
voice of... Thank you for the... Thank you.
$100 well spent.
The voice of pestilence dwells.
Do it, you coward!
Faye, thank you for the Hakka Supa.
Thank you.
The voice of pestilence dwells in the flames, leading the
pitiful souls to salvation.
Consign the crimson flame to its rightful place where you
shall be.
Welcome to capitalism.
Welcome.
What a What if I just shoot him?
Can I just shoot him?
I'm going to do it.
Do I take the shot?
Guys, I'm going to take the shot.
This is like sniper elite where you can shoot somebody in
the ball.
Do it?
Sorry to interrupt.
Oh, ow.
Should I've done that?
Oh, shit.
Maybe I shouldn't have.
Guys.
I might have made a mistake, guys.
Oh, this is it.
This is it.
Okay, nice.
Alright, don't worry.
I got the kick.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I got another grenade.
Another grenade.
Boom.
Ow.
It's okay.
That did nothing.
Okay.
whoa whoa you're still alive melee not anymore oh okay this
is not good this is not good guys this is not good i don't
know i feel like this is not a good time oh shit oh my god
guys i ran out of grenade does it look like i have a flash
grenade I know you guys want me to use a flash grenade.
Guys, oh, I do.
I do.
Oh, my God, it's time.
It's time.
This is it.
Oh, my God.
This is very unlucky.
Billy!
Triple kill!
Oh, no.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, my God.
He just got it.
It's fine.
You can't get closer to me.
It's okay.
He's burning.
Oh, no.
Not the one shot.
Oh.
Use a shotgun.
I don't have
it this is not not a good thing Leon We're super fucked up
right now.
Oh, I'm super fucked up There's no hot here.
So he's thinking for the magenta soup, but thank you.
Thank you Where is he?
Oh, what the fuck?
Why is he still here?
Oh my god
Okay, where's the red guy?
Is that the red guy?
I can't tell.
Where is he?
Where's the king?
Where's the king of all of this?
Bro, I'm just gonna fucking...
Ow, okay, I can't dodge that, apparently.
I can't...
There we go
Okay Oh what?
Oh what a waste What a fucking waste that's for sure Okay
Run run run run run Run run run run run
Run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run.
It's the only way.
There we go.
London is calling.
Guys, it was the only way!
Tux, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, it was the only way.
I was so scared.
I'm gonna accidentally kick the barrel.
I'm gonna want to kick the barrel, so I'm just gonna shoot
it from here.
Guys, I was scared I was gonna kick the barrel!
It was understandable!
I'm stupid enough to do it!
I truly see no other way.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, nice!
Loot!
Look at that.
We killed so many people.
yeah but what if i knife the barrel i could have knife the
barrel guys
bro i could have like stealthed that and killed everybody
with the chandelier i just realized i could have i could
have guys i just realized i could have saved so much ammo if
i just if i just stealthed and got to the chandelier why did
i do this to myself i can share hindsight yeah no way guys
guys i think i think i messed up
all right but it won't be us guys this is not a stealth run
Chat.
We're not pussies here.
Guys.
We're not cowards.
There's like money here.
I'm trying to like figure out where the fuck the money is.
Like here.
It's like here.
This is the Doki Run.
Exactly.
Doki Run is all murder.
Oh, I just missed money here.
The Doki Run is just purely murder.
murder.
The Doki run is also trying to fucking figure out where to
go.
Oh, it's like where I killed that guy.
It's right here.
Right here.
Wait, no.
It's not right here.
What the fuck?
Oh, where do I go?
Oh!
Where am I?
How do I get out of here?
Okay, I'm not trying to find Ludo.
I'm actually trying to figure out how to leave.
Oh, hey, on the statue?
Wait, there's a statue?
Behind me!
It was like...
Back in the OG room.
Right?
Guys.
Doki map.
There it is.
Nice.
Alright.
We made it.
We made it, guys.
Okay, cannot craft shotgun ammo.
Oh, thank god I have zero.
Oh, it's always poverty hours here.
It's just always poverty hours.
How do I get here?
Oh, I need Ashley.
Oh, this was like...
That's so funny.
I accidentally scammed all of you.
I thought you could use this door.
The shortcut.
There was only one way in.
All right, here we go.
Is that what I supposed to know?
There was one way.
I haven't played the remake.
The remake is so different from the OG.
Bro, it's been like almost three years.
How the fuck was I supposed to remember?
You can stop right there.
Ada!
Bacon, murder, looting, and extortion.
The classic Doki run.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, after six years, that is one hell of a greeting.
Six years?
Ada.
You don't seem surprised.
Has it really been six years, man?
Whoa.
Try using knives next time.
Better for close encounters.
My knife is $100,000.
$100,000.
More than Ashley.
What are you working for this time?
Oh, Leon.
Leave the girl.
She's lost no matter what.
You know that.
It's just a phase, Ada.
Maybe you'll live to meet me again.
And then I might get you that greeting.
Hey, last time I super chatted, I was asking you to throw
the boxes out in the super frantic and you threw one box,
fooling me twice to shame on me.
How about we continue?
Oh my
gosh, she disappeared.
She's so fast.
With magic.
She got that bug.
Grandma.
Did she just jump out the window?
She's bad, man.
Do you have fun?
Okay, there's no up.
Where the fuck is the jewelry?
Okay, we have no key.
Is there any bells to...
Oh, there's a chest right here.
Okay.
Nice.
Got the clock.
Alright, we don't have the key for this yet.
So, we gotta go forward.
Wait, what?
What did I miss?
Door?
What is this?
book this random book let's throw let's go graph c oh it's
this right oh we need two more okay i figured it out oh we
need three one more i figured it out i'm so smart we just
need one more it's right here
i'm so smart oh my god how does she do it It's like
everything was just in the room.
Okay.
What?
What do they mean?
Oh, I can rotate?
Oh!
Okay.
That's what they...
Who designed this puzzle?
Wait, but what the fuck are these?
I assume it's like this and no it has to be blue So I assume
that it's like that Right Not what What
It has to be blue Wait I get it I get it I get it I get it
Wait Okay what's behind this?
It's a shield Wait
Wait wait i get it i get it i get it
wait stop
god i'm so smart that should do it i figured it out let me
cook it's a puzzle for children all right i told you i
figured it out
all right we gotta go gotta go forward here the signal
echoes through the mountains rock becomes gravel and the
castle wall crumbles behold the crimson shade of the night
sky a river of tainted blood befoules the sea sacrifice your
life and the blood of your enemy atone for your ancient sins
i have no sin because i am a good person what's that sound i
don't like that sound I take it back.
Oh, money, though.
What the fuck was that?
What was that?
I have a shotgun.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
What was that?
There's a small key behind me?
You liar.
You fucking liar.
There is no key behind me.
There is no key.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck was that?
that.
What is that?
What was that?
Wait, what the fuck was that?
What the fuck was that?
Oh, there's the key.
Wait, I can go back.
I'm gonna go back.
I'm gonna unlock that drawer.
There is no need for me to be back there yet.
Gonna unlock this drawer.
It makes me feel safe.
Nice.
Ooh, pocket watch.
Money.
Alright, here I go.
Here I go.
Free loot.
Okay.
I don't want to deal with whatever is over there.
Guys, what chapter is Ashley missions?
This is very important.
Oh, God.
Why is the hallway so long?
Whoa!
What the fuck is that?
Holy shit!
That scared me.
the shit out of me oh my god did i actually scare the shit
out of me holy fuck is that spider what are you jesus christ
what the fuck are you oh my god you're getting too old for
this job man you're getting way too old for this job oh
thank god there you are I know, what the fuck was that?
Okay, selling.
Or an 8 mirror.
Okay, there's no...
Bro, I don't even have...
Oh, I have jewels here.
Okay, I have jewels for this.
Okay, wait.
We gotta do this.
It's money time.
Okay, double...
We need one of this.
And then one of this.
Wait, can I do triple double red?
Is that it?
1.2?
Yeah, double red.
Nice!
We got the double red.
And then...
That's it.
That's all I can do.
Okay, it's sell, sell, sell.
Uh, sell.
And then nothing else.
I don't have anything else.
I'm poor.
Yay!
Is there any other thing I can tune up?
Wait, is my body...
Oh my gosh, my body is so fucked right now.
okay uh i don't think there's anything i really need to
upgrade we're gonna hoard we're gonna keep hoarding our
money but i will do the rate of fire i can i i can like
spare a little bit max the upgrade of the pistol i don't
need okay i'll do the rate of fire We gotta save money to
make money!
Guys, we gotta save money to make money!
It's basic economics!
Save it for next game.
Wait, what?
Who said that?
What?
Oh.
fuck bro what he just stops talking bro why did you guys
told me to shoot the bell now i don't know what he wants me
to do
you said there'd be something special that'll happen
lord now now i don't have the lord
oh there's a special upgrade if i max it out Okay, I'll do
it.
What is it?
Guys, you fucking lied to me.
I got one guide again.
I got one guide.
I can't believe it.
No.
No!
Oh, it is.
You get it later.
No, no!
What's the lore?
I can't believe it.
I'll never know what the lore is.
I'll never know.
No, I have to live with the actions of my consequence.
I have to live with it, guys.
Guys, guys, we're not boulders gating this, guys.
Guys, we have to live with our consequences, guys.
We can't just fucking skip the lore whenever we want.
I know that's what you guys want.
Ow.
Fuck, okay.
Bro, fuck this.
I'm too tired of this.
I know it's that easy, but we can't just skip the lore
whenever we want, guys.
Oh my god.
Merchant, help me!
Wait, can they like not...
Wait, I can just be here.
Wait a minute.
Wait, that's great.
I can literally...
Wait, I can cheese it like this.
Alright.
That's great.
Wait, I can't shoot it from here.
Cheezing again.
The Doki Special!
Oh my god, he's so fast.
Oh my god, thank god it made him throw away his shield.
That's so good for me.
There we go.
Oh, wait, is he?
Okay, he doesn't mutate.
Okay, thank god.
Alright, nice.
We're fine.
Wait, you're still...
There's still one more?
Nice.
Okay, he's dead.
I'm pretty sure.
Thank God.
The Doki special.
If you can cheese it, there's a way.
Oh, it's a puzzle.
Okay, I'm going to make sure there's nothing up here first.
Okay, I think I see how this works.
Alright, I'm going to make...
What the fuck?
What is he doing here?
Get over here.
Get out of here.
What are you doing here?
Oh!
Wow!
all right give me a sec please get on him yes good good
that's very helpful
oh that is very helpful man stab stab stab there you go wait
now now that i know i can just stab him that is good that is
good now that i know i don't waste bullets from just i don't
waste bullets from the spotters i can just shank them let's
back to london we go okay we do this and then we go down and
then we open that door and then we go and then and then we
go the dokey special and then we go here and then we go
downstairs and then the doors open ta-da magic James thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you now I want to
replay the game damn it why do you do this to me all right
let's see I don't have enough for shotgun I'm gonna save up
for shotgun like I feel like the shotgun is more important
at this rate at the rate I'm fucking going drop down wait
which way oh no is this the treasure room this is not the
safe room shake shake shake shake shake shake shake shake oh
shit okay okay I did not think he'd be that close that was
an accident all right
Okay, I'm just gonna shoot with you here.
Okay, nice.
You don't know where I am.
There we go.
Good.
Ah!
Fuck!
There we go.
Okay, I did not fucking see her.
Not bad, right?
Jesus Christ.
I did not see her at all.
Oh, I scared the shit out of me.
Fuck, okay, at least we got shotgun ammo.
that is good we got shotgun ammo oh it's another puzzle come
on wait if that's a puzzle then what's over there wait
there's a treasure i'm looking up i'm looking up there's the
treasure treasure it's upstairs where the treasure It's
above me.
But how do I get above?
Huh?
It's like here.
Shoot the...
That's not the lantern.
There's a lantern?
It's not that one.
That's the fire lantern.
That's not it.
Is that the lantern?
That's the fire lantern, you idiots.
It's not this one.
That's the fucking fire lantern.
There's no jewelry here.
It's something.
It's above me.
I knew that was the fire lantern.
There was fire in it.
Like, what else could it be?
It was literally fire.
I'm just gonna kill this guy, though.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Come on.
Take another headshot.
There we go.
Oh, there he is.
You think you can scare me?
That's fucking right.
You thought you could scare me?
I see you.
I see you right there.
You fooling me.
Alright.
Let us go back for the puzzle.
It's puzzle time.
It's our favorite.
Puzzle time!
I love puzzles!
Alright, where is this?
Okay, press this.
My brain expands a little bit.
And then...
Whoa, Leon, you pull out the gun it's out of nowhere.
Hmm.
I hear something above me.
I see you.
That's fucking right.
You think I didn't see you there?
that's right what the wait i did not see you though i did
not where did you come from
okay he didn't turn okay thank god i was like wait i see you
but you okay money guys you need to drop something that's
not money guys please that's all i ask of you
we drop down from wait we drop down from here we're like
here wait no that has to be money money
money no no money
there's money
oh and then I do the And then I do the The lever I do the
lever And then I go back And then there's money There And
then I go back here
And then Money Money Oh fuck okay And then I My god I'm so
confused
I'm so confused Okay Okay, and then, and then I...
I go here?
I go here.
And then I go up.
And then I drop down.
And then money.
Money?
And then...
Wait, is there lantern here?
Lantern?
Is there lantern here?
Okay, and then I'll go up.
And then...
Okay, I do this.
Nice.
Okay, we're good.
We're okay.
And then I unlocked this.
And then everything is good to go.
The doorway in front of the ladder?
What's that gotta do with money?
And then I can open this door!
And then...
Money.
There we go, we did it.
We figured it out, guys.
there wait wait no what did i do wait no oh i missed out
that door so stupid
i think there was a door there kev i didn't see the door no
i did okay i'm just blind Okay, and then we go through here
and then and then we go up Here we go.
We're we're fucking thinking right now and then we go here
And then and then we we we turn on the lever here so it's
sunny now And then we we go here and then
wait I hear things and then we turn this lever
and then we go through this door and then we go down and
then money we did it oh gosh we're so smart what would you
guys do about me What would you guys do?
What will you guys do about me, chat?
God damn it.
Come on.
Come on, guys.
What will you guys do?
I feel like you guys cannot live.
You guys won't be able to function without this genius
brain!
Okay, we're gonna make sure we kill this guy, though.
Like, you cannot comprehend my logic.
That's how fucking ingenious I am.
Okay, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick.
Yes!
Got it in time.
And then- Oh, he's dead.
Okay, I thought I had to shank him.
Alright, nice.
I feel like this stage is taking much longer than it should.
Dude, how ingenious I am.
Wait, where does this close and open, though?
It's sun time.
Nothing?
Oh, okay.
It's morning now.
Is there anybody out here?
Oh, wait.
There's this.
What does that do?
I'll never know.
What the fuck did I just do?
What the fuck was that?
I'll never know I'll never know It'll always be my little
secret I don't like this What the fuck is that Excuse me
How?
How do I kill him?
Oh!
Why?
Can I kill him?
no okay guys apparently i can't kill him where do i go oh
god this way this way it's yellow it's yellow that means i
go here what is he gonna do throw that rock at me that's
fucking right you can't do jack shit follow the yellow
follow the shit okay there's no way this hits me right on
your scientific reasons this hits me guys there is a way for
this to hit me guys I found out there is a way there is a
way oh fucking grow get your knife
okay so apparently there was a why are you kidding bro this
is not fair this is not fair there should not be a way for
you to get over here this is not fair this is absolutely not
fair this fucking sucks this fucking sucks just keep running
okay just keep running just keep running just keep running
just keep running just keep running maybe if i go down here
is this sanctuary this is not sanctuary this is loot this is
just loot oh my god no please no let me up let me up oh wait
wait wait wait it's this way it's this way lever time
time love bird time and then i dropped down i did this out
of order i did this out what what do you mean what what do
you mean what do i do from here why am i trapped here why am
i trapped here
okay no oh thank god you die okay all right we're gonna
figure out this puzzle together.
I did this all out of order.
Okay, he threw the...
I'm gonna wait for him to throw one more time.
There's treasure in that room!
Okay, now we go back in.
Now we go... I'm panicking!
There is!
Okay, nice.
Alright, guys, I'm panicking.
I am panicking so fucking hard.
Brain no work when I panic.
Wait, the music stopped.
Is he like tired?
He's not tired.
He was not tired.
He was not tired, chat.
He was absolutely not tired, but it's okay!
I keep going!
Just keep running!
Just keep running.
You'll get there eventually.
I could have just knifed that, but I don't want panicking.
I could have literally just knifed it and not worried about
anything.
Oh my god, bro.
What the fuck?
What are you doing here?
I'm gonna shank you.
Bro, I'm gonna...
Bro, you guys don't deserve bullets.
We're good.
We're okay.
The best part about the archers is that they don't deserve
bullets.
the bullet like I can just shake them and they'll be fine
that's the best part I don't have to worry about I don't
have to worry about wasting my ammo but I knew how to do
combat I've always known what do you mean I just I just
don't want to They get close to me.
That's different.
I'm looking at this, bro.
Get ready.
Where is he?
Oh, God.
Thank God.
Holy shit.
That, like, was so long.
It took so long to move the cannon.
Who would have thought cannons are super fucking heavy?
Who would have fucking thought?
Oh, my God.
Cannons are heavy.
it took so fucking long to move that okay here you go down
i'll go i need to shoot the door oh but then i can shoot
this all right down i go i'm not done with the cannon oh
okay i never know when i'm done with the cannon What the
fuck?
Where did these guys come from?
Oh, it's nice that they're turning their backs for me.
Hello.
Goodbye.
Okay, maybe they turn around when they hit this area.
Do they actually turn around?
What if I shoot you in the legs?
Oh, Joe!
It doesn't work!
Nick doesn't work!
But do you turn around after?
Ha!
You do!
That's great.
But you actually do turn around.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright.
We go back to the cannon, apparently.
Where did the cannon go?
Alright.
I keep forgetting about the door.
Guys, it's so heavy to move the fucking cannon.
Oh my god.
I could have shot the cannon at them like last time.
You're right.
Could have just done that.
That would have made it so much easier.
I always make things harder for myself.
Why do I keep doing that?
Wait, there's loot here that I'm missing.
Where is that?
Here?
There's somewhere here that has loot.
Oh, here it is.
I don't have a key.
God damn it.
I never have the key.
Okay, I'm just gonna reload everything.
I never have the key for stuff.
Okay, shotgun.
Wait, shotgun.
Okay.
Throw the cannon at the chest.
Doki, just shoot.
Oh!
Fuck!
Oh my god.
Oh no, please don't tell me it's Crash Bandicoot.
No.
Oh, he's dead.
Okay, I just can't go back.
Oh my god.
I've had my filly, you guys.
Oh.
I thought I had to do a crash bandicoot or some shit.
Thank god.
Thank god I live.
I lived.
Alright.
Anything in here?
No.
Alright.
Oh my gosh, is this the garden?
Is this a maze?
God fucking damn it.
It's a fucking...
oh my god it's a dog maze it's super dog time where are you
oh no not super dog oh my god not super dog bro bro not
super dog oh god damn hey it's super dog
Ashley!
Ashley, I know it was just a phase, Ashley.
I know you didn't mean it.
I know you didn't mean it when you took my $100,000 knife.
Bro, you're a little girl.
You're gonna hurt yourself before you hurt me.
I wasn't myself anymore.
I was something else.
Ashley must have been terrifying now.
I know.
oh you too I'm morbbing it's okay to be afraid you know but
not more soon you got to keep moving forward we will beat
this together I don't know if I can you can just give me
heads up Before you stab me next time, okay?
Just yell out that you're gonna shank.
Just like me.
Just be like a Pokemon.
Ooh, nice.
92%!
Look at that.
Bro, I'm fucking gaming, man.
I'm fucking gaming.
all right we're seven more chapters all right we're kicking
good time we got to chapter 9 Louise where are you sorry I
screwed up come to my rescue Prince charming I'll show you
charming come on I'm in the ballroom past the courtyard
don't be late to the dance oh my god can I make Ashley hide
in the locker
Yes, I can.
I absolutely can.
Actually, you don't understand.
I will run away the moment there's trouble.
There is 100% chance I can leave.
Okay, it's all right.
No, it's not.
Get closer.
Can we get to...
I'm pretty sure I'm going to get above safe 100.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, no.
Wait, is Ashley coming with me to the dog maze?
Got it.
No!
Ashley, no.
No.
Why?
Why must you come with me to the maze?
Can you please get kidnapped?
Ashley, please, can you get kidnapped right now before I go
to the maze?
Please.
I am directionless.
Okay.
Ashley, please, I am so bad with mazes, Ashley.
I really can't have you with me right now.
I am so bad with mazes, Ashley, I swear.
Alright.
They owe me money.
Those fucking crows.
I'll never forget.
These crows owe me money.
Oh, fucking God.
Okay.
this out oh my god we have figured this shit out all
right we got one of them
god no no no oh yeah i got my shotgun ready for super dogs i
got it ready i'm so directionless i'm gonna get lost so fast
i can feel it already
Guys, I can already- Oh god, it's super dog.
It's super dogs.
Dog?
Doggos?
Where am I?
Oh, where am I?
I hear the toy.
Oh my god, I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Where is the toy?
Alright, here we go.
I like how people are trying to give me directions.
It's not.
Guys, it's hopeless.
You know damn well it's hopeless.
You can't fix this.
I know you guys think you can fix this.
But you can never fix this.
I will forever be directionless.
There's no fixing this.
Oh god, I hear the super dogs.
I hear them.
They're to my right.
Oh, that's all of them.
Wait, if I kill...
Oh!
Oh, fuck, I thought I was gonna kill all of them now!
Oh, my god!
Knife!
Kitchen knife!
I was like, okay, if I kill all of them before they got
out...
It didn't work.
I didn't manage to kill all of them before they...
Who would have thought...
Oh, and I thought I didn't kill all of them before they got
out.
Wow, Doki.
Super dog.
Super dog is coming.
Which way?
Which way are they coming?
I hear them, but which way?
This way!
I fucking knew it.
You can't hide.
You can't hide from me.
God, okay, wait.
How much ammo do I have?
Okay, we gotta...
Yeah, we definitely need a shotgun.
Okay.
Oh my god, there you found me.
There you go.
That's fucking right.
Idiot.
Oh, shit!
Oh, okay, he doesn't know.
He doesn't.
No, we're embattled, though.
It's just as lost.
The dogs are just as lost as me.
Oh, hey, chessboard.
Nice.
That's money.
Sweet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, the tiredness is taking me now.
Thanks for the stream, Doki.
It has been very fun.
I'll watch the rest of the VOD tomorrow.
Alright, thank you for watching this far.
We had a great time.
Have a great rest.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh my god.
Okay, he run.
No, god damn it.
God damn it.
He just fucking came in here.
He should try and gank me.
Okay.
I think you think I didn't see that?
I think I didn't see that dog?
Wait, did I kill him?
Did I, like, accidentally kill him?
He, like, just passed out at the end.
Nice.
Good.
I actually accidentally shot him.
Where is this area?
God, I'm so lost.
Where am I?
Okay, there's loot.
I'm so lost.
I remember we were stuck here for so long.
Because I kept getting...
Did I do this already?
Yes, this is the beginning.
this is this is the beginning this here here we didn't go
here i knew it there's a there's a box yellow box here we go
that's fucking right oh my god get out of here super dogs oh
no oh that's a lot of super dog oh god okay there we go okay
there we go killed them before they got me and they got a
flash grenade let's go
oh wait a minute i hear a dog don't think i didn't know
you're here i hear i play apex
everything hold this down hold this down don't think i can't
hear your fucking footsteps
that's right be careful of what okay i don't like that you
told me to be careful because be careful of what what do i
need to be careful of
yeah i have the sound dlc sound dlc if you're a good little
boy you too can get the sound dlc that means you're all bad
little boys and girls are you fucking kidding me where are
you ashley ashley run ashley run ashley ashley where did you
go no no way
No fucking way!
Oh my, I'm gonna shoot you in the fucking feet.
Oh shit, that's the wrong one that I shot.
There's dogs again!
Shit!
Okay, there we go.
I was gonna say, why are there dogs again?
Okay, there you go.
You should be dead dead.
Okay, thank God.
There's always dogs.
Not the dogs.
Are you fucking- where's the dogs?
Oh,
it's a freaking dog!
Okay.
I can't.
I really can't.
I can't deal with these.
I don't have the ammo.
I can't.
I don't- I'm fucking broke.
right now Ashley okay I think we're good I think we did it
are you fucking where where how are you alive no this
fucking random dog that just ran away trade what's this for
toilet these are three oh okay it's just money how have we
procured these curiosities these are all i don't have enough
there hasn't been like our mission upgrade nice that there's
pretty big enough to get the job done okay we definitely
need to do this all right oh okay nice oh my god there's so
much okay exclusive time wait okay we can sell we can sell
we can sell okay sell uh we need two We have all different!
Okay, let me sell these first.
And then we can...
An extraordinary...
Okay, imp that.
Alright, if it's all different, do we...
Five gems.
How many gems?
One, two, three, four.
Four, one.
Six.
I don't think we're gonna find...
I don't think we're gonna find, like, four of a kind.
I don't think so.
I think that's, like, almost impossible at this point.
So...
We can have one, two...
Oh, yeah, there's no way.
Yeah, there's definitely no way.
There's no way we can get that.
We can have all of this, though.
The different colors.
And then...
Stonks going up right now.
Look at that.
Bam!
Oh, yeah.
51,000!
Yeah, we're fucking...
Stonks going up.
Oh, my God.
Time to use it all up.
Okay, we're gonna...
repair our knife and then we're gonna upgrade our pistol and
our shotgun and our rifle yeah i think so power since these
are like our most uh our most fucking used guns will that be
all then yeah i already i already fixed my i fixed my armor
already we're fine armor's fixed.
All that money gone so fast.
All that money.
It's already gone.
Now I'm back in the lower tax bracket.
I hear the dog.
Wait, I just realized I don't even have shotgun shells.
Okay.
Are there any fish in the pond or did I kill them all?
Wait, do they respawn?
Wait, do the fishes respawn?
Oh my god.
This changes everything.
That fish respawned.
Yeah, I'd hear the dog, but he's not coming out.
Where's the objective?
I'm so lost.
How do we get there?
How do we...
Oh, gap in the wall.
How do we get there?
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Okay, we're just gonna grab the treasure over there first.
Yeah, I went the wrong door, guys.
I just realized.
But, like, there's a treasure over here anyway.
So, wait, do I have a key?
I don't have a key.
Yeah.
I went the wrong way.
Classic Doki.
Where's the dog?
Where the fuck is the dog?
Oh, there he is.
There's the dog.
There we go.
You have...
Oh, it's just money.
I don't care enough.
We have to go this way anyway.
wait how do i get there god damn it where am i oh there it
is this is where i have to go wait oh my god i don't care
enough to find that area okay don't care enough we're just
gonna
progress here you go
but the loot will go go back later we'll go back later it'll
be fine and she never goes back Chat She never comes back
Later Get some good news Now I can do more nasty upgrades
Nice That's basically what I saw Wait there's annoying blue
medallions Discord Oh okay That's just so easy That's easy
Oh my god It's that thing It's the It's the Bonus Wait a
minute this actually it's bonus time it's bonus time that is
it watch this actually watch this okay I have not I've never
used the TMP before so this is gonna be interesting oh is
this pirates oh these are all pirates okay I haven't used
these before okay 70 70 70 bullets oh I you know?
Ashley!
Stop backseating!
What?
Okay, this is a dumb gun.
This gun sucks.
How do you headshot that?
Okay, there's no way.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way.
Okay, you know, that's still an A.
Okay, guys.
That's still...
That's still there's a single shot.
Okay, right guys
Okay, nice.
Okay, this is easy It's just a shotgun
Nice reload time I'm reloading All right Okay, that is
bullshit how the fuck do I shoot that okay bro okay there
was no way there was no way to dodge that no way to dodge
that the spread guys the spread man it's the It was the
fucking spread.
Alright, what do I get?
Passable.
God damn it.
That's useless.
That's fucking useless for me.
Okay, we need one more.
We're sure single file in this.
I hate Ashley backseating me.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Boom.
Okay.
No.
We don't shoot.
Guys.
Reload time.
Come on.
Reload.
It's time to reload.
We need the spread.
I'm ready.
Thank god I never got the PMP.
PMP plus it sucks.
Oh fuck!
I'm sorry!
I got two trigger heads.
happy I'm sorry okay it's like two innocent people over like
300 people I killed if I only accidentally killed two of
them after like saving the world like I should get a pass I
should get a pass there like if I save the world and I only
killed two people like that's a win okay plus 15 ammo crack
bonus frequent i don't fucking know what that is but that's
literally all i have right now it's not a war criminal if i
save the world if i saved like 300 people and only two
people died it's called like it's like just unlucky okay
let's see where is my how do i customize my case again okay
i need to go to my typewriter there we go blues 40% off
resources wait I already have this which one is the oh there
you go oh I can only replay I can only put three at once buy
one bonus okay I feel like I'm not gonna craft the other
stuff alright nice okay we got Gotta go...
Jesus Christ, why is there so many fucking names here?
I don't have anything.
Where'd it go?
Here?
Okay, objective is here.
Can I go here?
Like, is there any reason to be here?
Is there any reason to be here, guy?
I don't know.
Should I be here?
I can't tell.
Oh, it goes back to an earlier area.
Fast travel.
I love fast travel.
Where is this place?
Where am I?
Oh!
Oh, I remember this place.
I remember.
It's the part where I was trying to find the fucking bell.
It's a bell!
Yeah, but I don't have any keys.
See?
I couldn't find any keys.
So like, there's nothing to unlock.
Because I don't have a key.
We'll come back later when we find a key.
This way.
Okay.
Yeah, but we don't have keys.
Yeah.
Hey, this is it.
Red guy.
Who the fuck is red guy?
She does not come back.
It was from this moment on, Chad knew she did not come back.
Don't worry guys, I'm gonna come back everybody.
Don't worry.
We're gonna come back.
Let's see.
This way.
Wait, is there anything here?
No, it's locked.
It's locked.
Where?
Oh, hey, can I shoot that?
Actually, no, why would I shoot that?
I could knife it.
Let's see.
Oh, there's...
Oh, I forgot to shoot the medallions.
I almost forgot about the medallions.
Medallions.
Okay, there's a medallion above me?
Question mark?
Medallion?
What the fuck is...
Is it below me?
Maybe I'm gonna shoot this one first, though.
I'm gonna shoot that one first.
Since it's over there, anyway.
Okay.
We're gonna go this way.
Oh, what's this?
Okay, we need the Cerberus head.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, it's like here.
I was like, where is that?
Rats have infested a section of castle.
They're gnawing away at all the precious books.
But those heretics couldn't care less.
Okay, it's time to shoot the rats as well.
There's so many things to shoot.
So little time.
There's only one Leon.
I assume this is the library.
Oh my god, where do I go?
What the fuck is this?
Guys, there's...
Okay, I don't know where to go.
There's way too many entrances.
There's way too many things.
Here.
And there's a symbol on the wall.
I have to do all the rooms?
I do?
Alright.
Let me figure this shit out.
Okay, we'll go this door first.
This is gonna be a long chapter.
I can tell.
No, it's the snake room!
No!
Okay, let me...
I'm saving.
I'm saying I'm getting I'm getting a snake PTSD
I'm getting snake PTSD I'm getting snake PTSD right now okay
okay statue of some snakes Okay, let's see.
All right.
Dining hall.
This puzzle tab.
No thanks.
Where's the rat?
It was a rat?
Oh, rat!
Here we go.
We got the rat.
Pest control is here.
Wait, what?
Order.
Sit there.
Oh, I can like have her sit there while I do this puzzle.
That is so nice of her.
Okay.
Oh, oh, okay.
I got this.
All right, I need you to sit.
Okay.
Napkin.
Two, two, two knives.
Spoon fork.
Napkin.
Two knives.
Spoon fork.
Napkin.
That's three.
Two knives.
Wait, is there bread?
No, no bread.
Napkin, two knives, spoon fork.
Go here.
Sit here.
You do a lot of missions like this?
Okay, my turn.
Well, yeah.
Let's see.
I'm not used to having such good company.
Okay.
Three knives, two forks, one spoon.
Oh, I'm here.
I sit here.
This is my spot.
I did it.
Yeah!
We're so smart.
Oh, this isn't the bad snake room.
I thought this was the one where the fucking guy with the
knives thing, you know, like the knife arms, and then he
slashes me.
I thought it was this room.
It's not this room, so it's the other rooms.
If it's not this room, it's gonna be the other room.
Yeah, the cage fight.
I thought it was the cage fight.
Oh, there's the red herb.
Yeah.
Don't worry, Wolf eventually gets to that room.
I can feel it.
Check the map.
Dallion.
Dallion?
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
Thanks for the reminder.
Okay, and then we gotta go here and okay we gotta go like
this apparently
almost got all right here we go
okay who has the snake head we might as well give him the
snake head now i still left this guy oh i don't even have to
do the puzzle for this he just thank god thank god is
automatic
all right here we go is this combat this is has to be combat
oriented there's no way leon there's some armor bet you
could use it like a bulletproof vest little old fashion on
my taste oh i can feel it i feel the i feel the gun fight
oh there you go don't worry about shotgun I have my shotgun.
Don't worry.
All right, here we go.
Oh, here we go.
Actually, let's go save our game.
Before we go downstairs, there's a base here anyway.
So it's good that I came back.
All right, Ashley, we're gonna save the game.
Don't have much.
So let's save.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
I could see.
The lion is like in the center.
That worries me a little bit.
It tells me that I have something to worry about.
Alright, here we go.
go all right it's time to fight i have my shotgun
Ashley stay up there okay be careful Hmm
Okay, you can't be serious Wait, what I wish I had the flash
grenades now Okay Oh,
it's a guy
Wait, I can shake I forgot to shake I was like, what is
this?
That's...
Don't worry, Ashley.
All right, nice.
Okay, shank time, shank time.
Shank!
Wait, what's this?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Man, wouldn't it be great if I had, you know...
You know, if I had...
Nice, nice, that's good, that's good, that's good.
It would be so great if I had put...
King!
Have the flashbang!
Man, that would be so convenient.
Okay, I got this though.
It's okay.
It's okay, I got this.
Nice.
Oh, it wasn't as bad as I thought.
Thank God.
It's not as bad as I thought.
Oh, thank God!
Is there more?
What the?
Oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, I
didn't see these two.
Okay.
No, no, no, reload, reload, reload.
Please throw the flame!
Ashley, throw the flame!
Holding it!
Ashley, how did you miss the flame?
I have to lead them, Ashley!
There you go.
So stop being useless.
Ashley, please.
How did you miss?
Oh, God.
Ashley, you have...
Did you run out?
Did you run out, Ashley?
Ashley.
Okay.
There we go.
Thank fucking god.
Kick!
Oh, I didn't waste too much ammo at least.
Oh, the moment I said that.
The moment.
The moment I said that, I missed two shots.
What is my life?
Yeah.
Nighty night.
Nights.
Okay, we won't pick her up yet.
Okay, now we can.
I have to get the loot.
Classic turkey.
Yeah, I'm okay.
Don't worry with your aim.
Don't worry, I definitely did not get burned.
Oh my god, give me the loot.
Give me the fucking loot.
Okay, nice.
Oh, hey.
Oh, you fucking...
Hey guys, I found the flash grenade.
Guys, don't worry.
Flash grenade next fight.
Chat, we can have the flash grenade next fight.
Chat, don't worry.
Just in time.
Okay, let's see.
We got to open this.
Okay.
All right, here you go.
Hey, man, is that so nice that I found it?
It's great, guys.
I found it just in time.
Oh, nice.
I knew there was a medallion here.
I felt it in my soul.
Not from the map.
It was from the soul.
I don't think they're gonna move, do you?
Oh, I caught the cube.
Wait, the cube.
Oh, rat!
Nice.
Nice flick.
That was a good flick.
Not gonna lie.
Hey.
Right here.
All right, save...
Wait, not save yet.
We gotta get the cube.
Cube time.
Oh, okay.
It's a puzzle.
Okay, no, that's a circle.
Where's the square?
Uh...
How do I...
Oh, here!
Nice.
So smart.
We did it!
The square goes in a square hole.
Okay, we need the...
What other opens the cube?
I think there's a cube in one of these, right?
Was there a cube treasure here?
Yeah?
Alright, we go back.
It's fast travel time.
Fast travel!
Come over, Ashley.
We're cubing.
I know my shapes.
Hey, this is it.
Okay, this way.
It's money time.
Guys, we need to upgrade.
We need to upgrade.
It's money time.
Oh, it leads back here.
Oh, what the?
What the fuck?
okay
hello what the fuck okay
what the fuck Ashley get back next okay here you go Ashley
come move Ashley what are you doing I'm serious oh my god i
swear to god ashley i swear to fucking god ashley i swear to
god i have to reload my god ashley what are you doing oh my
god what the fuck is ashley doing
Christ, I swear.
I...
I gotta...
God, Ashley.
She's out.
She's just trying to help, donkey.
She was so helpful, chat.
She really was incredibly helpful.
Okay, time to do the cube.
It's cubing time.
God damn it.
Okay, it's this way.
Okay, I'm trying to find the circular one.
Oh my god.
Where?
Where is it?
Okay, maybe it's here?
No.
Okay, this is difficult.
This is...
Cat.
Too stupid for this.
Okay.
Oh my god, you can...
There's Q&E.
There's Q&E!
I didn't realize...
I didn't realize there was Q&E!
Ah!
I didn't realize there was another rotation.
Okay, I figured it out.
I wasn't reading.
I was just pressing buttons.
What is...
oh my god okay let me sell this let me sell this okay let's
see we don't have wait is this circular oh it's circular it
is oh they're all circles i don't have circles okay 3000 we
need to help our thing here and then our knife is okay right
now it's okay we i think i'm gonna say for this we need to
save up for like gun upgrades we're gonna save for gun
upgrades shapes though he does not do well with shapes okay
we're gonna put this here and then I'm not gonna fix this
I'm not gonna fix my inventory all right we're fine yeah all
right that guy that was like you're gonna miss the red guy i
finally now know what he meant by that okay oh my god those
animals thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
it's okay i think we made it nobody cares about what the
inventory looks like no one cares It's still usable.
As long as it's usable.
That's all that matters.
Mally meant.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The last boss.
The puzzle.
Right here.
Reading.
The worst boss of them all.
Oh, it's hurting your OCD.
let me make it better for you there you go oh hey there's a
vase there nice I'm
helpful all right this oh no it's the cube room oh
no not this room okay where are they are they they
didn't hear that right guys do you think they hurt that no
right no right I think I'm fine I think I'm fine I don't
think they hurt that okay it's locked all right so I they
didn't hear i had a silencer on it try to see where the
others are i know like no how did he see me what no how did
i miss too what the
boom okay out of the way
how did i I missed.
Shake, shake, shake!
Don't shake!
Do not shake!
I can't be bothered!
Where?
Okay.
He did?
He did.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Okay, there you go.
Reloading, reloading, reloading.
Oh, shit!
Boom!
Bye.
Oh, fuck!
Shit, get over here, Ashley.
I'm sorry, Ashley.
Shake!
Okay, there you go.
Oh, my god, please.
No!
Okay.
Kick!
Ha!
Nice.
You want leg.
Oh no.
Leg!
Shink!
There you go.
You're all dead.
Ashley.
You're fine.
Yeah, thanks.
Oh, we're okay.
Shinking always works.
Remember to always shink, guys.
Remember to always shink.
Shink.
Oh.
Kink.
There we go.
There's always shanking time.
One more just to be sure.
You gotta double-shank, man.
You always have to double-shank, guys.
Okay.
Where the fuck is a rat?
I'm still missing one more rat.
Almost shanked.
Actually, she's fine.
If she's not fine, she would tell me right ashley right
ashley you would tell uncle leon if it's not fine you
remember that just tell uncle leon if it's not fine just let
me know i ran past it where the fuck was the rat
wait there's a green oh there is a greener nice
no rats here this is a clean area This area is clean.
It isn't until after Ashley...
What the fuck do you mean?
What do you...
I don't like that.
Okay, here we go.
Nice.
We're doing it, Ashley.
We're fucking doing it.
Okay, we gotta reload our...
We gotta reload our rifle.
All right.
Up we go.
Hoop.
Can we unlock this door?
Oh, there it is.
Nice.
There you go.
We got the goat head.
Yay!
Hoop.
Oh my god, look at all this ammo.
It's like I never wasted anything other than the flash
grenade.
What?
Sorry, sorry, that scared the shit out of me.
I wasn't ready for that.
Oh, God, okay, okay.
I was like, what do you mean, watch out?
Like, what do you mean?
I couldn't tell what he meant.
Next.
Alright, shake, shake, shake, shake, shake.
There we go.
nice she did yeah like 20 seconds later it's not helpful
that's not helpful oh i missed ammo did i oh i did bro i
missed out like resources and wait i missed out on resources
and flash grenade we gotta go back actually we have to go
back actually we have to go back it's like we never lost
anything now it's like we never lost anything look at that
I'm just blind as always treasure under the bridge oh oh hey
treasure yeah treasure it's just a yellow diamond that's the
shittiest treasure And then there is shotgun shells.
Wait, where the fuck is that?
Oh, it's like over here?
How the fuck do I get there?
Oh, it's at the top.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
We're learning, Ashley.
We're getting better.
Where is that?
What?
Oh!
It's on the fucking banister.
Sorry, it was on the banister, guys.
Alright, here we go.
Nice.
We did it, Ashley.
We fucking did it.
We're gamers.
We're fucking gaming.
so proud of us actually you and i you and i against the
world okay we gotta save now oh yeah we did let's get that
request real fast nice how much money do i have i still
don't have a lot i'm still broke as uh yeah we need like
anything will you what if i like sell ashley to him and then
like i'll buy Ashley back so then like I like I mean like
because he's everywhere so then I don't have to what if I
pay you to babysit Ashley can I pay him to babysit Ashley
that'd be so convenient man if he likes money that much like
a pawn shop
alone Ashley wait a minute on the stairs what stay back
run now no that was the ashley part not the ashley chapter
not the ashley chapter
no one fear you one fucking One fucking fear.
I won't run.
Wait for me, Leon.
Oh no!
One fucking fear!
The nightmare begins.
Oh my god, the true hell away.
Real hell.
Alright, here we go.
Oh god, alright, here we go.
Real hell here.
Oh my god, dude, fuck off!
Oh, there's a rat.
Can I fuck?
punch the rat i can't punch the fucking rat okay this is
real hell this is real why do you walk so slow god
this is the worst part this is the worst part this is the
worst part of this game i don't have gun i don't know gun
hell the resting for bears answers to the chosen time If
it's the Lord's blessing you seek have courage and oh, yeah,
thank you.
Thank you.
I'm gonna just gonna have courage Thank you Guys, can I like
skip guys, please just backseat me, you know Guys, please
cool, please just tell me just tell me
Please just just tell me the time you kept me out of here
please please maybe guys i have an idea i have an idea
eventually i'll use my wooden keyboard guys i have an idea i
have okay what if what if
oh hell actual hell actual hell i honestly thought it would
be a new chapter and then i can be like new chapter i guess
we'll play it next time
i lose gun now i don't know what to do no gun no game no gun
No gun confused.
What to do when you have no gun?
What do you do?
Oh my god.
What is life without a gun?
I know this section is inspiring any eye-shotted because she
loves this.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Be right back.
I'll be right back.
Alright, here we go.
Go fast, gotta go fast.
If I go fast, I can't get scared.
Weeeeee.
If I keep running.
Oh yeah, I got a key.
Keys.
Wait, what?
The fuck was that?
what was that what was that what was that what was that guys
if i keep running no be gone be gone uh
fish i don't know this
oh wait wait elevator elevator elevator
okay here we go oh no oh no oh no
Get me out!
Where's Leon?
I'm still running!
He told me to run.
I'm still running.
No, I'm not.
I'm not okay.
Demon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm taking my favorite super chat.
Devastator.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, the insignia, the key to getting out of this confined
place is the Salazar family insignia.
The final that must venture to wear the cursed armor awaits
the underground.
Oh, no, not the underground.
What's the scene?
What's the scene on?
Okay.
Oh, merciful Lord.
Enact your righteous justice upon the wicked usurper, the
maniacal monster, Raymond Salazar.
Amen.
Your blessed blue light protects you.
forever you faithful servant oh no come on yes this is it
this is it we can figure this out
oh we can we can figure this out this is it this is 1104
okay That's, wait, I did it.
I knew it would eventually work.
I knew it would eventually work, guys.
I fucking knew it.
Does this mean I can skip everything now?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is it.
This is it.
This is not it.
Nice is not it.
Wait, what?
Okay, we're gonna shine this.
And then...
Shine.
Where am I?
Oh, I have to go all the way back!
Don't look back!
back!
Where's the clock?
11 04!
There we go.
We did it.
We did it, guys.
We're gamers.
I can't believe it.
11 04.
I speedrun!
I don't know.
I just figured it out guys i just i i just kept i just knew
come on come on no no no no no no no no no no people go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go okay and
then we go and then we go and then we go but no
one likes Ashley levels no one likes the Ashley levels don't
fucking pretend don't don't be righteous with me right now
okay Don't act all fucking righteous.
What's this?
Eagle.
Wait, what is this?
Wait, that's everything.
Eagle, fish, snake, crow.
I like it right now.
Well, I'm doing it!
Are you not entertained?
Oh, yeah, I'm the same, Ashley.
Finally, I can relate to you!
Finally some relatability.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, I'm ready!
Oh my god, please get me out of here!
Oh.
What is this?
Moon.
Okay.
Um, what is this?
Is this a star or a moon?
Oh wait, no.
Oh my god, it's right here.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Moon.
Star.
Thank god.
This is it?
No?
It's not the right moon?
How's there meant?
How's there more moons?
Oh, there we go.
That was a big moon.
Okay.
I had the wrong moon.
I sound tired.
I'm playing Ashley, man.
Anybody who will be tired playing this level, I feel like I
age 80 years playing Ashley.
Oh,
God.
Oh, God, tell me I just run!
No!
Come on!
Ashley, don't look back!
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, I mean, let me just use this key, I guess.
Guys, this is important.
Guys, don't worry.
We're gonna figure out the key.
Guys, this is very important.
We We got an emerald, guys.
This is so important.
We got an emerald.
Good nights and stay still.
Guys, this is important.
This is important.
Where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
Get up!
Oh, God.
Oh, fuck.
This is good.
This is bad.
Press the elevator!
Press the button!
Okay.
We're good.
Goodbye.
Okay.
All right.
Here I am.
I don't know where to go.
Where do I go?
Where?
How do I get there?
How do I... What?
There we go.
Just keep running.
Just keep running Where do I go?
Where do I go?
Do I go here?
Here?
I don't know where to go
straight do I go straight all of the where's the blue light
where's the blue light I don't know where to go no don't go
straight library I swear I feel like you're fucking with me
right now library and up the st- here here here here
here yes okay okay okay here here okay okay here not there
i'm so confused
go back oh my god oh i can't wait Where?
Oh my god.
I got baited!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, this is it.
This is it.
Here, here, here.
Almost there!
We're doing it, Ashley!
The power of backseating!
Where?
Oh, here!
Let me out!
Oh my god, the power of backseating!
Run, girl, run!
Holy fuck, god damn it.
Oh shit, man.
I hate this- I hate Ashley Love-
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
Can make it down?
I can catch you.
Oh.
Yeah, I think so.
Thank God.
Leon, please give me your gun.
No, Ashley, what happened?
After everything I did.
After everything, Ashley.
oh my god he turned his back for literally two seconds oh my
god oh my god the fucking ashley man fucking ashley oh the
fuck is sorry nothing yet what is that but my little helper
is creating quite the commotion that's that's ashley right
everything for ashley is fine as long as you can keep your i
don't know i know like ada's supposed to be like some
fucking assassin like some robot assassin but like i don't
like the voice acting for how mechanical she sounds but
don't come crying to me if you get bit is that wester
all right leon changed your mind hey ada i just went through
hell for you seems like something big is about to go down in
the throne room babysitting is tough huh hey oh god it was
it was so hard oh my god all right we're calling it here i
think i honestly think this is a this is a good place to
call it
Ashley part, I'm done.
We'll finish the game.
We'll finish Resident Evil next week, guys.
We're gonna finish Resident Evil next week.
All it took was the Ashley level.
Yes, 100%.
Ashley level is what makes or breaks the game.
The Ashley level is what ages me.
Like, I'm insane.
The moment we're at the Ashley level, I'm mentally checked
out.
I'm so fucking checked out, guys.
Anyway, I think I really lost the chats coming in, so I'm
going to call it here, everybody.
I am really tired now.
Like, I was fine.
I was fine until Ashley.
Then I was not so fine anymore.
But, yeah.
Also, I guess a little up.
update a little update uh but you guys just don't follow me
on twitter um if you purchase the buttons the pinback
buttons for the lunar new year merch they'll be uh shipped
out uh sooner than the estimated shipping date because i
have a like those like those like uh button makers uh and i
make them myself so like uh they will be shipped out soonish
uh so yeah look forward to that if you
like ordered.
Oh, only for the buttons, though.
If you order, like, other items with the buttons, they'll be
shipped when the other items are there.
But you only order the buttons, then, like, they'll be
shipped out sooner.
So, yeah, that's the only other things I have for all of you
guys.
I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
I am so exhausted from fucking Ashley Love.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.